From the biggest stadiums To the coziest holes in the wall From house parties to porch hangs to pride celebrations From your favorite fuss shop to your local Indian spot From noodle bars to sports bars to salsa bars There's a Molson with your name on it Canadian ultra XL
从最大的体育场到最温馨的街角小店，从家庭派对到门廊聚会再到骄傲游行，从你最爱的精品店到当地的印度餐馆，从面馆到运动酒吧再到萨尔萨舞吧，总有一款莫尔森啤酒为你而生，加拿大超大号。
Molson Everyone in Must be legal drinking age Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents if you feel at any time you need support Please contact your local crisis center for suggested phone numbers for confidential support Please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website The names of several individuals in this episode have been changed Superbike motorsports in Chesney, South Carolina wasn't just the motorcycle dealership
莫尔森，人人皆可享用，必须达到法定饮酒年龄。我们的剧集涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件，如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系当地的危机中心获取保密支持的电话号码。请查看您应用内或我们网站上本集的节目说明。本集中几位当事人的姓名已作更改。南卡罗来纳州切斯尼的超级摩托车运动中心不仅仅是一家摩托车经销商。
For bike enthusiasts in the small town and its surrounding area The store was a place to hang out with like-minded people and even make friends 30-year-old Scott Ponder who owned the store worked there with his best friend Brian Lucas who was 29 The dynamic between the pair had added to the friendly atmosphere There were a number of regular customers who dropped by whenever they had spare time That was exactly what Noel Lee was doing on the afternoon of Thursday, November 6th, 2003 Noel had met Scott and Brian through the store and grew to consider them two of his closest friends The trio were all planning to go to a motocross race the following night and Noel wanted to stop by the store to collect the tickets
对于这个小镇及其周边地区的摩托车爱好者来说，这家店是一个与志同道合的人聚会甚至结交朋友的地方。30岁的店主斯科特·庞德与他29岁的挚友布莱恩·卢卡斯一起在那里工作。两人之间的互动增添了友好的氛围。有许多常客只要有空就会顺道过来。这正是诺埃尔·李在2003年11月6日星期四下午所做的事情。诺埃尔通过这家店认识了斯科特和布莱恩，并逐渐将他们视为自己最亲密的朋友。三人原计划第二天晚上去看一场摩托车越野赛，诺埃尔想顺道去店里取票。
He called the shop first at around 2 30 p.m. To check if this suited Scott's mother 52-year-old Beverly Guy answered the phone She helped out at the dealership with bookkeeping and other administrative tasks Beverly said it would be fine for Noel to drop in At around 3 p.m. Noel pulled his BMW into the store's parking lot Set back from a stretch of a two-lane highway called Paris Bridge Road Superbike motorsports was one of the only retail spaces in the vicinity It boarded a cattle field and was surrounded by rolling hills and mostly residential buildings
他先是在下午2点30分左右给店里打了电话，确认这个时间是否方便斯科特的母亲。52岁的贝弗利·盖伊接了电话，她在店里帮忙处理簿记和其他行政事务。贝弗利说诺埃尔随时可以过来。下午3点左右，诺埃尔把他的宝马车开进了店里的停车场。超级摩托车运动中心坐落在一段名为巴黎桥路的双车道公路旁，是附近仅有的几家零售店之一。它紧邻一片牛场，周围环绕着起伏的丘陵和大部分住宅建筑。
Noel parked in one of the five car spaces directly in front of the shop He immediately noticed something strange in the doorway of the dealership Sprawled across the ground in a manner that propped the glass door open was a person It was the store manager Brian Lucas Noel Lee got out of his car Assuming Brian was playing some kind of prank Noel moved towards the storefront when he abruptly stopped in his tracks Partially hidden beneath the bonnet of the car. He'd parked next to was the body of Scott Ponder a Pool of blood had formed around him
诺埃尔把车停在店门前五个停车位中的一个。他立刻注意到店门口有些异样。一个人横卧在地上，挡住了玻璃门，使其处于开启状态。那是店经理布莱恩·卢卡斯。诺埃尔·李下了车。他以为布莱恩在搞什么恶作剧，便朝店门口走去，却突然停下了脚步。在他旁边停放的汽车引擎盖下，部分遮挡着斯科特·庞德的尸体，他周围形成了一滩血迹。
Closer up Noel could see there was blood around Brian as well The glass from the door held open by his body had been shattered Realizing the severity of the situation Noel raced past Brian's body and into the store He headed to the sales counter and used the dealership's phone to call 911 Then he saw something else A third body was sprawled on the floor just outside the showroom in the middle of the dealership It was Scott's mother Beverly Guy When Noel got through to a 911 operator he cried out
走近一看，诺埃尔发现布莱恩周围也有血迹。被他身体挡住的玻璃门上的玻璃已经破碎。意识到情况的严重性，诺埃尔冲过布莱恩的尸体进入店内。他径直走向销售柜台，用店里的电话拨打了911。然后他看到了另一幕。在店中间的展厅外，地板上横卧着第三具尸体。那是斯科特的母亲贝弗利·盖伊。当诺埃尔接通911接线员时，他大喊道：
Apparently everyone's been shot up here Everybody's laying down in a pool of blood. His mum has been shot the mechanics been shot Although Noel had only seen three bodies he believed that there would be a fourth somewhere as well Chris Sherbert the dealership's 26 year old mechanic was always working at this time Of day often in the garage area Explaining this to the operator Noel was told not to go looking for Chris Instead he should leave the store for his own safety and wait outside for the first responders to arrive Noel did as he was told exiting the dealership and walking across the road where he sat down in some grass
“这里好像所有人都被枪杀了，每个人都躺在血泊中。他妈妈被枪杀了，技工也被枪杀了。”虽然诺埃尔只看到了三具尸体，但他认为第四个人也应该在某处。26岁的店里技工克里斯·谢伯特通常在这个时间工作，经常在车库区域。诺埃尔向接线员解释了这一点，但被告知不要去寻找克里斯。相反，为了自身安全，他应该离开商店，在外面等待急救人员到达。诺埃尔照做了，他走出商店，穿过马路，坐在草地上。
Police descended on Superbike Motorsports and secured the building Scott Ponder, Brian Lucas and Beverly Guy were all deceased As Noel Lee had predicted the dealership's mechanic Chris Sherbert was also at the shop He was found slumped over a black Suzuki motorcycle in the dealership's garage He was dead too All four victims had been shot multiple times with a 9mm pistol Including at least once in the chest and once in the forehead The headshots implied that the killings had been a deliberate execution rather than a random mass shooting
警察赶到超级摩托车运动中心并封锁了建筑物。斯科特·庞德、布莱恩·卢卡斯和贝弗利·盖伊均已死亡。正如诺埃尔·李所预料的那样，店里的技工克里斯·谢伯特也在店里。他被发现倒在车库里的一辆黑色铃木摩托车上。他也死了。所有四名受害者都被9毫米手枪多次射击，包括至少一次胸部和一次前额。头部中弹意味着这是一场蓄意的处决，而非随机的大规模枪击。
The perpetrator had missed very few of their shots even though some of their victims had been moving targets 18 shell casings were recovered from the scene They were dusted for prints but yielded none Nor were there any unidentified hand or fingerprints elsewhere in the store Investigators also had no luck sourcing foreign DNA The only clue they came across was a bill of sale for a black Suzuki Motorcycle It appeared as though Scott Ponder had been in the process of writing the bill when the shootings began
凶手几乎没有射偏，尽管一些受害者当时正在移动。现场回收了18枚弹壳。警方对弹壳进行了指纹提取，但一无所获。店里其他地方也没有发现任何无法识别的手印或指纹。调查人员在获取外来DNA方面也没有进展。他们发现的唯一线索是一张黑色铃木摩托车的销售单。看起来斯科特·庞德在枪击开始时正在填写这张单据。
It didn't include a buyer's name or any other identifying information such as a credit card number The bill was for the same black Suzuki that mechanic Chris Sherbert had been working on He had been prepping it for his new owner When he was shot and killed To police it seemed likely that the buyer of the black Suzuki and the shooter were one and the same Based on the locations of the body they put together a theory of how the slayings had likely unfolded The shooter had left the store after arranging to buy the bike Then they had sneaked into the garage via a car and went to the police
单据上没有买家的姓名或其他任何身份信息，如信用卡号。这张单据是为技工克里斯·谢伯特正在处理的那辆黑色铃木摩托车开具的。他当时正在为新车主做准备，结果被枪杀。对警方来说，黑色铃木的买家和凶手很可能是同一个人。根据尸体的位置，他们推断出了杀戮可能发生的过程。凶手在安排购买摩托车后离开了商店。然后他们通过汽车潜入车库，并前往警察局。
After arranging to buy the bike then they had sneaked into the garage via a rear door They shot Chris Sherbert from behind while he was preparing the motorcycle for delivery Next the gunman headed through the showroom encountering Beverly Guy and killing her Scott Ponder and Brian Lucas had heard the gunshots and were fleeing the scene as the shooter pursued them Brian was gunned down in the store's doorway Scott had made it a little further outside to the parking lot After incapacitating all four victims the shooter had methodically walked to each one and fired a final shot into their foreheads Investigators shut down Paris Bridge Road for three days as they processed the crime scene
在安排购买摩托车后，他们通过后门潜入车库。他们在克里斯·谢伯特准备交付摩托车时从背后射杀了他。接着，枪手穿过展厅，遇到了贝弗利·盖伊并杀害了她。斯科特·庞德和布莱恩·卢卡斯听到了枪声，在枪手追赶时试图逃离现场。布莱恩在店门口被枪杀。斯科特则跑得稍远一点，到了停车场。在制服所有四名受害者后，枪手有条不紊地走到每个人身边，向他们的前额补了最后一枪。调查人员封锁了巴黎桥路三天，以处理犯罪现场。
The attack was thought to have taken place at around 2 45 p.m Superbike motorsports customer Noel Lee had called the store at around 2 30 p.m and spoken to Beverly Guy She'd just dropped by to run some errands after taking her mother to a chemotherapy appointment Beverly was planning to deposit some earnings at the bank but told Noel to drop in as Scott and Brian would both be there By the time Noel arrived 30 minutes later, they were all dead Although many vehicles drove by the store throughout the day, there weren't that many customers around in the middle of a weekday afternoon Consequently investigators didn't have many eyewitness accounts to go on A couple who were known to deal drugs had been seen near the store near the time of the shooting
袭击被认为发生在下午2点45分左右。超级摩托车运动中心的顾客诺埃尔·李在下午2点30分左右给店里打了电话，并与贝弗利·盖伊交谈过。她当时刚送完母亲去化疗，顺道过来办些杂事。贝弗利计划去银行存钱，但告诉诺埃尔可以过来，因为斯科特和布莱恩都会在店里。当诺埃尔30分钟后到达时，他们都已经死了。虽然全天有很多车辆经过商店，但在工作日的下午，店里并没有多少顾客。因此，调查人员没有多少目击者证词可供参考。一对以贩毒闻名的夫妇在枪击发生时曾出现在店附近。
The woman had appeared upset and was heading away from superbike motorsports as her male partner chased after her Officers managed to track the couple down but cleared them of any involvement in the crime Several vehicles were also spotted in the area One was Rad and an early 90s model, perhaps a Honda Civic or Chevy Cavalier Another was a dark blue late model Chevrolet pickup truck with chrome exhaust and bed rails And the third was a smaller sportier pale blue pickup truck Officers asked for anyone with information about these vehicles to come forward Very quickly the murders at the superbike motorsports were being compared to another attack that had taken place five months earlier
那名女子看起来很不安，正从超级摩托车运动中心离开，她的男性同伴在后面追赶她。警官们设法找到了这对夫妇，但排除了他们与犯罪的任何关联。该地区还发现了多辆车辆。一辆是红色的，90年代初的车型，可能是本田思域或雪佛兰卡瓦利。另一辆是深蓝色、较新款的雪佛兰皮卡，带有镀铬排气管和车斗栏。第三辆是一辆较小的、更具运动感的浅蓝色皮卡。警官们呼吁任何有这些车辆信息的人站出来。很快，超级摩托车运动中心的谋杀案就被拿来与五个月前发生的另一起袭击案进行比较。
31 miles southwest of Chesney in the town of Greer, there had been a robbery at Blue Ridge Savings Bank on May 16 A bank teller and two customers had been shot and killed execution style in a back room Just like the superbike shootings, the bank attack had taken place in the middle of the day with no witnesses around It didn't appear to be random And similar to the location of superbike motorsports, the Blue Ridge Savings Bank was near a highway in a relatively isolated area A red car was seen driving to the bank at 1 24 p.m. Six minutes before the shooting and a red car was spotted near superbike motorsports as well As of November 2003, the perpetrator of the bank shootings hadn't been caught or identified
在切斯尼西南31英里的格里尔镇，5月16日发生了一起蓝岭储蓄银行抢劫案。一名银行出纳员和两名顾客在后室被以处决方式枪杀。就像超级摩托车枪击案一样，银行袭击发生在光天化日之下，没有目击者。这看起来并非随机事件。而且与超级摩托车运动中心的位置相似，蓝岭储蓄银行靠近高速公路，处于相对偏僻的地区。一辆红色汽车在下午1点24分被看到驶向银行，即枪击发生前六分钟，而一辆红色汽车也被发现在超级摩托车运动中心附近。截至2003年11月，银行枪击案的肇事者尚未被抓获或确认身份。
However, while money was stolen from the bank in Greer Investigators knew almost immediately that the superbike slayings hadn't been part of a robbery Nothing had been taken from the store, not even an envelope full of cash that had been left on a counter Presumably the deposit Beverly had been planning to make The store also had numerous expensive items and a gold plated award that Scott had received, none of which were touched With the robbery ruled out as a motive, investigators believed they were looking at a more personal attack Scott Ponder had opened a superbike motorsports in January 2001 and the business had gone from strength to strength Scott hired his best friend Brian Lucas, who was a skilled mechanic as well as a fellow motorcycle expert
然而，虽然格里尔银行的钱被偷了，但调查人员几乎立刻就知道超级摩托车谋杀案并非抢劫的一部分。店里什么都没丢，甚至连柜台上放着的一信封现金都没动，那大概是贝弗利计划去存的钱。店里还有许多昂贵的物品和斯科特获得的一座镀金奖杯，这些都没有被触碰。排除了抢劫动机后，调查人员认为这是一起更具针对性的个人袭击。斯科特·庞德于2001年1月开设了超级摩托车运动中心，生意蒸蒸日上。斯科特聘请了他的挚友布莱恩·卢卡斯，他不仅是一位技术娴熟的技工，也是一位摩托车专家。
The pair's genuine passion for motorbikes was appealing to customers As one of the largest Suzuki dealerships across two counties had attracted a lot of clientele in the area But Scott wasn't satisfied with the just selling locally He utilized the internet to sell to customers all over the United States At the beginning of the 21st century online shopping was still in its infancy This put Scott ahead of the curve As well as stocking motorcycles, superbike motorsports also sold ATVs and go-karts This widened their customer base to outdoor enthusiasts and young families
两人对摩托车的真诚热情吸引了顾客。作为两个县内最大的铃木经销商之一，它吸引了该地区大量的客户。但斯科特并不满足于仅仅在当地销售。他利用互联网向全美各地的客户销售。在21世纪初，在线购物还处于起步阶段。这让斯科特走在了时代前沿。除了销售摩托车，超级摩托车运动中心还销售全地形车和卡丁车。这扩大了他们的客户群，涵盖了户外运动爱好者和年轻家庭。
In its first year, the store made more than $1 million in sales This allowed Scott to expand quickly, remodeling and extending the dealership's garage and taking on more staff Had Scott's success made he store the target of a rival business who was looking to get rid of their competition There were also rumors that the killer could have been a disgruntled customer One person who'd recently visited the dealership told the media that he'd seen buyers quote totally flip out upon receiving expensive bills Investigators also heard stories that superbike's prices were sometimes considered excessive The dealership's customer base was examined, but no one stood out as suspicious
在第一年，该店的销售额就超过了100万美元。这使得斯科特能够迅速扩张，改造并扩建了店里的车库，并雇佣了更多员工。斯科特的成功是否让这家店成为了竞争对手的目标？也有传言称凶手可能是一名不满的顾客。一位最近访问过该店的人告诉媒体，他曾看到买家在收到昂贵的账单时“彻底崩溃”。调查人员还听说超级摩托车的价格有时被认为过高。店里的客户群受到了审查，但没有人显得可疑。
The investigative spotlight highlighted Noel Lee, the friend of Scott and Brian's who had discovered the crime scene Noel had a cell phone, but it stepped over his friend's bodies and entered the store to call 911 from the phone inside For all he knew, the killer might have still been in the building Yet, Noel opted to go in anyway He had also told the 911 operator that the dealership's mechanic had been shot Even though he supposedly hadn't seen Chris Sherbert's body or entered the garage at all Noel couldn't explain why he'd used the store's phone instead of his own except that he hadn't been thinking clearly due to shock He had presumed that Chris had been shot as well because the other three employees all were
调查的焦点转向了发现犯罪现场的斯科特和布莱恩的朋友诺埃尔·李。诺埃尔有手机，但他跨过朋友的尸体进入店内，用店里的电话拨打了911。据他所知，凶手可能还在楼里。然而，诺埃尔还是选择了进去。他还告诉911接线员店里的技工被枪杀了，尽管他理应没有看到克里斯·谢伯特的尸体，也没有进入车库。诺埃尔无法解释为什么他用店里的电话而不是自己的，只能说是因为震惊导致他思维混乱。他推测克里斯也被枪杀了，因为其他三名员工都遭到了枪击。
Noel was fingerprinted and had his car dusted for prints. He also took a polygraph test None of these results gave officers any further reason to be suspicious Noel Lee was cleared from the suspect list Sheriff's deputies discovered that Chris Sherbert had been scheduled to front court several days later on Monday, November 10 He had been charged with some drug-related offences Some suspected that he was planning to turn state's witness and testify against others in exchange for having the charges dropped If this was the case, investigators wondered whether the murders were committed by someone who wanted to silence Chris But this theory failed to gain momentum
诺埃尔被采集了指纹，他的车也被提取了指纹。他还接受了测谎仪测试。这些结果都没有给警官们任何进一步怀疑的理由。诺埃尔·李被从嫌疑人名单中剔除。警长副手发现克里斯·谢伯特原定于几天后的11月10日星期一出庭。他被指控犯有一些与毒品有关的罪行。有人怀疑他计划转为污点证人，通过指证他人来换取撤销指控。如果是这样，调查人员想知道谋杀案是否是想让克里斯闭嘴的人所为。但这一理论未能获得进展。
Investigators were also interested to learn that Scott Ponder hadn't really known his father He had been raised more by his stepfather, Terry Guy Scott's biological father, William Dean Ponder, had an extensive rap sheet dating back to 1976 It included property crimes, weapons violations and drug and alcohol offences In mid-1993, William had just been released from a stint in prison and was living in his parents' home on Parris Bridge Road Directly across the street from the store his son would open almost a decade later On the night of Saturday, August 28, 1993, 41-year-old William went out drinking with some friends at a nearby bar He failed to return home
调查人员还饶有兴趣地了解到，斯科特·庞德并不真正了解他的亲生父亲。他更多是由继父特里·盖伊抚养长大的。斯科特的亲生父亲威廉·迪恩·庞德有着自1976年以来的大量犯罪记录。其中包括财产犯罪、武器违规以及毒品和酒精犯罪。1993年中期，威廉刚从监狱服刑期满释放，住在巴黎桥路他父母的家中。那条路就在他儿子近十年后开设的商店对面。1993年8月28日星期六晚上，41岁的威廉和朋友去附近的一家酒吧喝酒。他没能回家。
Five days passed with no word from William He was then reported missing His friends claimed they'd dropped him off at the intersection of Parris Bridge and Martin Camp Roads But William was never heard from again Ten years later, as Scott Ponder turned 30 and was preparing to become a father himself, he began digging into his biological father's mysterious disappearance It was known that Scott was trying to find his dad at around the time he was killed Investigators wondered if perhaps somebody hadn't wanted him to succeed Prior to his death, Scott had attempted to make a call from his cell phone which was found with his body
五天过去了，威廉杳无音讯。随后他被报告失踪。他的朋友声称他们把他送到了巴黎桥路和马丁营路的交叉口。但威廉从此再无音讯。十年后，当斯科特·庞德年满30岁并准备自己成为父亲时，他开始调查亲生父亲的神秘失踪。众所周知，斯科特在被杀时正试图寻找他的父亲。调查人员想知道是否有人不希望他成功。在去世前，斯科特曾试图用他的手机拨打电话，手机在他尸体旁被发现。
He had managed to dial the numbers 333 It was theorized that he'd been trying to call the number listed as the third favorite contact in his phone His wife, Melissa Brackman Melissa was originally from Arizona She'd met Scott several years earlier and the pair had commenced a romantic relationship after a period of being good friends Melissa was currently seven weeks pregnant with the couple's first child Just two days earlier, on Tuesday, November 4, Melissa and Scott had attended their first prenatal check-up together and had listened to their baby's heartbeat for the first time
他设法拨出了数字“333”。据推测，他当时正试图拨打手机中列为第三个常用联系人的号码。他的妻子梅丽莎·布拉克曼。梅丽莎来自亚利桑那州。她在几年前认识了斯科特，两人在做了一段时间好朋友后开始了浪漫关系。梅丽莎当时怀有七周身孕，是这对夫妇的第一个孩子。就在两天前，即11月4日星期二，梅丽莎和斯科特一起参加了第一次产前检查，并第一次听到了宝宝的心跳。
On the morning of Thursday, November 6, Melissa stayed in bed a little longer to curb her morning sickness After a sleep in, she headed to work She and Scott spoke on the phone a couple of times that day, the latest call being at around 2.15 or 2.30 p.m. Not long after that, Melissa headed out on a work errand when she received a call from Scott's credit card vendor The vendor explained that she was trying to head over to Superbike Motorsports to perform a routine check on Scott's credit card machines But there was a roadblock preventing access to the store She had heard a rumor that there'd been a shooting in the area and wanted to check if everything was okay After hearing this, Melissa immediately changed direction and headed to Superbike Motorsports
11月6日星期四早上，梅丽莎为了缓解晨吐在床上多躺了一会儿。睡了个懒觉后，她去上班了。她和斯科特那天通了几次电话，最后一次是在下午2点15分或2点30分左右。不久之后，梅丽莎出去办事时接到了斯科特信用卡供应商的电话。供应商解释说她正打算去超级摩托车运动中心对斯科特的信用卡机进行例行检查。但通往商店的道路被封锁了。她听说该地区发生了枪击事件，想确认一切是否安好。听到这个消息，梅丽莎立即改变方向，前往超级摩托车运动中心。
She repeatedly called Scott's cell phone and office number along the way, but none of her calls were answered As Melissa drew closer to the store on Parris Bridge Road, she saw the area was swarming with police and media helicopters Her efforts to get to the store were interrupted by officers who escorted her back home after learning who she was When officials informed Melissa that Scott had been shot and killed at work, she asked to speak with Scott's mother, Beverly It was then she was told that the entire staff of Superbike Motorsports were dead By the time Melissa gave birth seven months later, the investigation into her husband's murder had stalled Melissa had named her son Scott Jr after his father, but everyone took to calling the little boy Scotty Roughly a year after the shootings, investigators met with Melissa for a regular catch-up
她在路上反复拨打斯科特的手机和办公室电话，但都没有人接听。当梅丽莎靠近巴黎桥路上的商店时，她看到该地区挤满了警察和媒体直升机。在得知她的身份后，警官们护送她回家，打断了她前往商店的努力。当官员们通知梅丽莎斯科特在工作中被枪杀时，她要求与斯科特的母亲贝弗利交谈。就在那时，她被告知超级摩托车运动中心的所有员工都死了。当梅丽莎七个月后分娩时，对她丈夫谋杀案的调查已经陷入停滞。梅丽莎给儿子取名斯科特二世，以纪念他的父亲，但大家都叫这个小男孩“斯科蒂”。枪击事件发生大约一年后，调查人员与梅丽莎进行了一次例行会面。
She brought baby Scotty with her and had to change his diaper at one point After the meeting, investigators retrieved the discarded diaper from the rubbish Melissa was unaware that the catch-up was a ruse Investigators had received a tip-off from the police Investigators had received a tip-off that Scott Ponder had been sterile and wasn't able to father children They obtained a DNA sample from baby Scotty's diaper and compared it to Scott Ponder's DNA, which was taken from the crime scene It wasn't a match Melissa Brackman was asked to attend the Spartanburg County Sheriff's Department
她带着小斯科蒂一起来，中途不得不给他换尿布。会面后，调查人员从垃圾中取回了丢弃的尿布。梅丽莎不知道这次会面是一个圈套。调查人员收到警方的线报，称斯科特·庞德患有不育症，无法生育。他们从婴儿斯科蒂的尿布中获取了DNA样本，并将其与从犯罪现场提取的斯科特·庞德的DNA进行了比对。结果不匹配。梅丽莎·布拉克曼被要求前往斯帕坦堡县警长办公室。
This time she should leave Scotty at home Deputies ushered Melissa into a meeting room and shut the door One deputy then informed her Your son's DNA does not match up with his father's Melissa appeared stunned by the revelation She insisted that wasn't possible and offered to have Scotty's DNA tested again Investigators agreed The result was the same
这次她应该把斯科蒂留在家里。副警长将梅丽莎带进会议室并关上了门。一名副警长随后通知她：“你儿子的DNA与他父亲的不匹配。”梅丽莎对这个消息感到震惊。她坚持认为这不可能，并提出让斯科蒂的DNA再次进行检测。调查人员同意了。结果是一样的。
However, a familial link was found to exist between Scotty and another victim from Superbike Motorsports Testing confirmed that Scott's best friend Brian Lucas was the father of Melissa's son Brian had also been married and had two sons with his wife But his mother Lorraine Lucas had suspected he wasn't entirely happy in his relationship About two weeks before the shootings Lorraine had been visiting her son and noticed that his wife seemed to be pulling faces as Lorraine and Brian chatted Brian grew unhappy about this and stated This is my mother. I want you to treat her with respect This led to an argument between the couple
然而，调查发现斯科蒂与超级摩托车运动中心的另一名受害者之间存在亲缘关系。检测证实，斯科特的挚友布莱恩·卢卡斯是梅丽莎儿子的父亲。布莱恩也已婚，并与妻子育有两个儿子。但他的母亲洛林·卢卡斯曾怀疑他在婚姻中并不完全幸福。在枪击事件发生前约两周，洛林曾探望过她的儿子，并注意到当她和布莱恩聊天时，他的妻子似乎在做鬼脸。布莱恩对此感到不满，并说：“这是我母亲。我希望你尊重她。”这导致了夫妻间的争吵。
Brian had also been looking at new houses without his wife's knowledge On the day of his murder, he had gone to visit one property with a friend of his who was a realtor It seemed plausible to investigators that Brian and Melissa had been having an affair Perhaps the murders were the result of this secret somehow coming to light Scott's stepfather Terry Guy was especially troubled by the infidelity rumors He'd not only lost his stepson in the shooting, but his wife Beverly as well Terry had suffered depression in the aftermath of their deaths and lost 70 pounds due to grief and stress When he heard that Melissa could have been involved he sat her down and asked
布莱恩还在瞒着妻子看新房子。在他被谋杀的那天，他曾和一位做房地产经纪人的朋友去参观过一处房产。对调查人员来说，布莱恩和梅丽莎有染似乎是合理的。也许谋杀案是这个秘密以某种方式曝光的结果。斯科特的继父特里·盖伊对这些不忠的传言感到特别困扰。他在枪击事件中不仅失去了继子，还失去了妻子贝弗利。特里在他们死后患上了抑郁症，由于悲伤和压力瘦了70磅。当他听说梅丽莎可能牵涉其中时，他让她坐下并问道：
Did you have anything to do with it? If proof comes out that you did wherever you're at, I'll come and get you and bring you back myself Melissa was adamant she wasn't involved in the slayings and refused to admit that she'd been having an affair For 18 months investigators continued to pursue this line of inquiry They ran more DNA tests and received another unexpected result According to their samples, Beverly Guy hadn't actually been Scott Ponder's mother They compared Beverly's DNA to Brian Lucas's sample revealing a match As investigators knew this couldn't be possible, they worked to discover what had happened
“你和这件事有关吗？如果证明你参与了，无论你在哪里，我都会亲自把你抓回来。”梅丽莎坚称她没有参与杀戮，并拒绝承认她曾有过婚外情。调查人员继续追查这条线索长达18个月。他们进行了更多的DNA测试，并收到了另一个意想不到的结果。根据他们的样本，贝弗利·盖伊实际上并不是斯科特·庞德的母亲。他们将贝弗利的DNA与布莱恩·卢卡斯的样本进行了比对，结果显示匹配。由于调查人员知道这不可能，他们开始调查到底发生了什么。
Scott and Brian's DNA samples had gotten mixed up when they were taken at the crime scene with Scott's sample marked as Brian's and vice versa This had likely happened because the two bodies were lying almost side by side This revelation was hugely vindicating for Melissa Brackman From the beginning she had insisted that she'd never cheated on her husband and knew that he was her baby's father Melissa suffered from endometriosis and Scott had a low sperm count which had resulted in the couple needing medical assistance to conceive Scottie
斯科特和布莱恩的DNA样本在犯罪现场采集时被搞混了，斯科特的样本被标记为布莱恩的，反之亦然。这很可能是因为两具尸体几乎并排躺着。这一发现对梅丽莎·布拉克曼来说是巨大的平反。从一开始，她就坚持说她从未背叛过丈夫，并知道他是她孩子的父亲。梅丽莎患有子宫内膜异位症，斯科特的精子数量较低，这导致这对夫妇需要医疗辅助才能怀上斯科蒂。
Since the beginning of the investigation she had been open and honest with the sheriff's deputies handing over love letters she and Scott had written to each other and answering intimate questions about their relationship Melissa had even agreed to be polygraphed When investigators told her that both DNA tests proved that Scott wasn't Scottie's father she was willing to have her husband's body exhumed so another sample could be taken With the DNA bungal exposed, Melissa's name was cleared but she still suffered the fallout from having been suspected
自调查开始以来，她一直对警长副手坦诚相待，交出了她和斯科特写给对方的情书，并回答了关于他们关系的私密问题。梅丽莎甚至同意接受测谎。当调查人员告诉她两次DNA测试都证明斯科特不是斯科蒂的父亲时，她愿意将丈夫的尸体挖出来，以便采集另一个样本。随着DNA乌龙事件的曝光，梅丽莎洗清了嫌疑，但她仍然承受着被怀疑带来的后果。
In the 18 months that had passed since this line of inquiry began one of Scott's grandmothers had died believing he'd never fathered a child Having lost her husband and her reputation, Melissa moved back to her home state of Arizona Kelly Sisk was a member of the National Guard and a regular customer at Superbike Motorsports On the day of the shootings he decided to stop in at the store to make a payment on a go-kart he was buying for his four-year-old son Kelly took his son with him and the pair arrived at the store around 2pm
在这一调查方向开始后的18个月里，斯科特的一位祖母在相信他从未生育过孩子的情况下去世了。失去了丈夫和名誉，梅丽莎搬回了她的家乡亚利桑那州。凯利·西斯克是国民警卫队的一员，也是超级摩托车运动中心的常客。枪击发生那天，他决定顺道去店里为他给四岁儿子买的卡丁车付款。凯利带着儿子一起，两人在下午2点左右到达商店。
They spent between 30 and 45 minutes wandering around the dealership floor admiring the latest bikes and ATVs It was quiet with only one other customer in the store The other customer was a white male who looked to be between 25 and 40 years old He was about 6 feet tall and 170 to 200 pounds with dark feathered hair, thin lips, small eyes, and a narrow jaw The man was wearing jeans and a leather jacket The man was wearing jeans and a leather jacket which struck Kelly as odd because it was a warm day The customer was admiring a black Suzuki motorcycle when Kelly saw Scott Ponder approach him
他们在店里逛了30到45分钟，欣赏最新的摩托车和全地形车。店里很安静，只有另一位顾客。另一位顾客是一名白人男性，看起来在25到40岁之间。他身高约6英尺，体重170到200磅，留着深色的羽毛状头发，薄嘴唇，小眼睛，下巴狭窄。那人穿着牛仔裤和皮夹克。那人穿着牛仔裤和皮夹克，这让凯利觉得很奇怪，因为那天天气很暖和。当凯利看到斯科特·庞德走近那名顾客时，他正在欣赏一辆黑色铃木摩托车。
Hey, this is a good beginner's bike, Scott said Kelly was confused The bike was big and didn't look suitable for a beginner in his opinion But he figured Scott would know better than he did When Kelly and his son left a few minutes later the customer was still chatting with Scott By the time Kelly arrived at home reports about the quadruple homicide at Superbike Motorsports were all over the news Kelly was shocked He couldn't believe that he'd just been there with his young child right before the attack unfolded
“嘿，这是一辆很好的入门级摩托车，”斯科特说。凯利很困惑。在他看来，这辆车很大，看起来不适合初学者。但他想斯科特应该比他更懂。当凯利和儿子几分钟后离开时，那名顾客还在和斯科特聊天。当凯利回到家时，关于超级摩托车运动中心四人谋杀案的报道铺天盖地。凯利震惊了。他不敢相信就在袭击发生前，他刚带着年幼的孩子在那里待过。
Kelly reported what he had seen to the Spartanburg County's Sheriff's Department But it would take more than a month for investigators to track him down They eventually came to realize that Kelly's sisk was their most crucial witness The man that he'd seen in the dealership that day was most likely the killer Kelly helped them create a composite sketch of the suspect and the image was widely distributed But Kelly wasn't happy with the picture He didn't think it was a good likeness of the man at all No solid leads resulted from the suspect's sketch
凯利向斯帕坦堡县警长办公室报告了他所看到的情况。但调查人员花了一个多月的时间才找到他。他们最终意识到凯利·西斯克是他们最重要的证人。那天他在店里看到的那个人很可能就是凶手。凯利帮助他们制作了嫌疑人的合成素描，该图像被广泛分发。但凯利对这张照片并不满意。他认为这根本不像那个人。嫌疑人的素描没有带来任何实质性的线索。
It was featured on popular television programs such as America's Most Wanted and Unsolved Mysteries Tips would trickle in after each screening but nothing that led to a break in the case Former FBI agent and renowned serial killer profiler John Douglas was brought in to create a profile of the unknown suspect In his opinion, the killer was mission-oriented The entire attack was probably over within 45 seconds and the motive was very different to other crimes Douglas had investigated Quote It's not a type of case like other serial killers who I've interviewed where it's a fantasy This is revenge
它出现在《全美通缉令》和《未解之谜》等热门电视节目中。每次播出后都会有零星的线索，但没有一条能让案件取得突破。前联邦调查局特工、著名的连环杀手侧写师约翰·道格拉斯被请来为这名未知嫌疑人建立侧写。在他看来，凶手是任务导向型的。整个袭击可能在45秒内就结束了，动机与道格拉斯调查过的其他犯罪截然不同。他说：“这不像我采访过的其他连环杀手案件那样是某种幻想。这是复仇。”
This is retaliation In 2012 an updated sketch of the suspect was released which I witnessed Kelly's sisk said was a much better likeness of the mystery customer It depicted a man with dark hair parted down the middle and a face that was wider at the top and narrowed towards his chin His eyes were somewhat narrowed and his mouth turned downwards at the corners In November 2013 the sheriff's office sent out a letter to their database of superbike motorsports customers in the hopes It might jog someone's memory No one responded to them More than a decade after the shootings there had been over 750 leads that all fizzled out
“这是报复。”2012年，嫌疑人的更新版素描发布，目击者凯利·西斯克说这与那位神秘顾客更像。它描绘了一个留着中分深色头发的男人，脸部上方较宽，向颌部收窄。他的眼睛有些眯起，嘴角向下。2013年11月，警长办公室向他们的超级摩托车运动中心客户数据库发送了一封信，希望能唤起某人的记忆。没有人回应。枪击事件发生十多年后，已经有超过750条线索，但都无疾而终。
But sheriff Chuck Wright refused to admit defeat telling the Spartanburg Herald Journal in 2015 I don't call it a cold case. I call it an old case Because we're still working on it Here's the new Ad-Ville Plus Acetaminophen It combines two of the most popular ingredients to fight pain in uncompromising practices The ibuprofen targets pain at the source and the Acetaminophen blocks the signs of pain by bringing a quick and effective relief from pain up to eight hours Conquering the words of the head quickly thanks to the anti-painting relief to double the action of the new Ad-Ville Plus Acetaminophen At the beginning of September 2016 a woman named Joanne Schifflett was worried about her son
但警长查克·赖特拒绝承认失败，他在2015年告诉《斯帕坦堡先驱报》：“我不称它为悬案。我称它为旧案，因为我们仍在努力。”这是新的Ad-Ville Plus对乙酰氨基酚。它结合了两种最流行的止痛成分，以不妥协的方式对抗疼痛。布洛芬从源头靶向疼痛，对乙酰氨基酚通过阻断疼痛信号，带来长达八小时的快速有效缓解。感谢双重作用的新Ad-Ville Plus对乙酰氨基酚，快速征服头痛。2016年9月初，一位名叫乔安妮·希夫莱特的女士开始担心她的儿子。
32-year-old Charlie Carver who lived in Anderson County, South Carolina hadn't replied to a text message Joanne had sent him This was very out of character The two normally spoke of the same thing This was very out of character The two normally spoke every day When Joanne did some digging she found out that she wasn't the only one who hadn't heard from Charlie lately His father hadn't spoken to him in days either Charlie and his new girlfriend 30-year-old Alana Jones had also failed to show up for a dinner scheduled with one of Alana's friends on Wednesday, August 31
住在南卡罗来纳州安德森县的32岁的查理·卡弗没有回复乔安妮发给他的短信。这非常反常。两人通常每天都会说话。当乔安妮进行调查时，她发现最近没有收到查理消息的不止她一个人。他的父亲也好几天没和他说话了。查理和他的新女友、30岁的阿兰娜·琼斯也没有出现在8月31日星期三与阿兰娜朋友预定的晚餐上。
Alana had been excited to introduce Charlie to her friend so it seemed odd that they never arrived or explained their absence The last time anyone had heard from the couple was during the day of August 31 When people tried to call them their phones went straight to voicemail Joanne Schifflett decided someone needed to check the apartment in Anderson where the couple lived Charlie and Alana had only started dating a few months prior but had already moved in together Charlie's car was missing from the complex but Alana's was still on site On Saturday, September 3 Joanne asked the building's manager if she could check on her son The manager agreed to perform a welfare check
阿兰娜一直很兴奋地想把查理介绍给她的朋友，所以他们没到场也没解释原因显得很奇怪。最后一次有人收到这对情侣的消息是在8月31日白天。当人们试图给他们打电话时，电话直接转到了语音信箱。乔安妮·希夫莱特决定需要有人去检查这对情侣在安德森住的公寓。查理和阿兰娜才约会几个月，但已经同居了。查理的车在公寓区不见了，但阿兰娜的车还在现场。9月3日星期六，乔安妮请大楼经理帮忙查看她儿子的状况。经理同意进行一次福利检查。
She knocked on the apartment's door Nobody answered The manager let herself in The couple weren't there but all of their clothing and prescription medication had been left behind along with Alana's glasses and contact lenses Alana's dog, a Pomeranian named Romeo was all alone in the residence with no food or water It looked as though he'd been neglected for several days Alana's loved ones were adamant that she would never take off without making sure Romeo was cared for The dog was like a baby to her and she loved him dearly
她敲了公寓的门。没人回答。经理自己进去了。这对情侣不在那里，但他们所有的衣服和处方药都留在了原地，还有阿兰娜的眼镜和隐形眼镜。阿兰娜的狗，一只名叫罗密欧的博美犬，独自留在住所里，没有食物和水。看起来它已经被忽视了好几天。阿兰娜的亲人坚信，如果不是确保罗密欧得到照顾，她绝不会离开。这只狗对她来说就像孩子一样，她非常爱它。
Although the couple's friends and family knew something must be wrong for them to disappear without warning and fail to make contact Police were less concerned They suspected the pair had just decided to go away together for a few days Missing person reports were filed for both Alana and Charlie But law enforcement in Anderson County said there was little else they could do It didn't take long for the couple's loved ones to rally and start searching for themselves Charlie's father wondered if perhaps they'd gotten into an accident in Charlie's 2002 white Pontiac Grand Prix He searched creek beds and ravines throughout the county in case they'd gone off the road
虽然这对情侣的朋友和家人知道他们毫无预兆地消失且无法联系一定出了问题，但警方并不太担心。他们怀疑两人只是决定一起出去玩几天。阿兰娜和查理都被报了失踪。但安德森县的执法部门表示他们能做的很少。没过多久，这对情侣的亲人就开始团结起来，自行展开搜寻。查理的父亲想知道他们是否在查理那辆2002年的白色庞蒂亚克大奖赛车上出了事故。他在全县的溪床和沟壑中搜寻，以防他们冲出了路面。
Meanwhile, Charlie and Alana's friends started Facebook groups seeking information and handed out flyers plastered with the couple's descriptions Alana was five foot eight with short dyed red hair and green eyes Charlie was six foot with brown hair, blue eyes, glasses and a neatly truncated red eyes and a trimmed beard Photos on the flyers showed the couple both individually and together with their smiling faces pressed together as Alana snapped a selfie As time wore on police joined in the search They submitted applications to obtain data from the couple's cell phones which had either died or been switched off A month went by with no answers and people began to fear the worst that the couple hadn't been in an accident
与此同时，查理和阿兰娜的朋友们建立了Facebook群组寻求信息，并分发了贴满这对情侣描述的传单。阿兰娜身高5英尺8英寸，留着染红的短发，绿眼睛。查理身高6英尺，棕色头发，蓝眼睛，戴眼镜，留着修剪整齐的红胡子。传单上的照片显示了这对情侣单独和在一起的照片，阿兰娜自拍时他们笑脸相贴。随着时间推移，警方也加入了搜寻。他们提交了申请，以获取这对情侣手机的数据，这些手机要么没电了，要么被关机了。一个月过去了，没有任何答案，人们开始担心最坏的情况，即这对情侣并非遭遇了事故。
But had met with foul play Charlie and Alana's parents all appeared on national television segments to raise awareness about the double missing persons case Then on Saturday, October 1 New posts suddenly appeared on Charlie Carver's Facebook page for the first time in over a month It appeared he was using the account to log major life events retrospectively He posted that on Friday, July 1 2016 he and Alana discovered they were expecting a baby girl Exactly one month later on Monday, August 1 they bought a house And a month after that on Thursday, September 1 the couple got married
而是遭遇了不测。查理和阿兰娜的父母都出现在全国电视节目中，以提高对这起双人失踪案的关注。然后，在10月1日星期六，查理·卡弗的Facebook页面上突然出现了新的帖子，这是一个月多以来的第一次。看起来他正在使用该账户回顾性地记录重大生活事件。他发帖称，2016年7月1日星期五，他和阿兰娜发现他们即将迎来一个女婴。整整一个月后的8月1日星期一，他们买了一栋房子。一个月后的9月1日星期四，这对情侣结婚了。
Rather than reassuring their friends and family the posts on Charlie's page alarmed them None of these milestones fit with what they knew about the couple and they still hadn't heard anything from them The posts didn't stop there Although Charlie had never been a big social media user, odd memes and out-of-character comments were suddenly cropping up all over his page One read I wonder if I said hello, how many people would say it back? Let's try it Hello
这些帖子不仅没有让他们的朋友和家人感到安心，反而让他们感到惊恐。这些里程碑事件与他们所了解的这对情侣的情况完全不符，而且他们仍然没有收到任何消息。帖子并没有就此停止。虽然查理从来不是一个社交媒体重度用户，但奇怪的表情包和不符合他性格的评论突然出现在他的页面上。其中一条写道：“我想如果我说你好，会有多少人回应？让我们试试。你好。”
Another featured lyrics from the song Hotel California by the Eagles Last thing I remember I was running for the door. I had to find the passage back to the place. I was before Relax said the nightmare we are programmed to receive You can check out any time you like but you can never leave One of the most disturbing posts read Sometimes late at night I dig a hole in the backyard to keep the nosy neighbors guessing Charlie's friends were certain he wasn't making these posts and suspected that the person responsible for the couple's disappearance was behind them They began commenting on the posts
另一条包含了老鹰乐队《加州旅馆》的歌词：“我记得的最后一件事是我跑向门口。我必须找到回到我之前所在地方的通道。‘放松，’梦魇说，‘我们被设定为接收。你可以随时结账，但你永远无法离开。’”其中一条最令人不安的帖子写道：“有时在深夜，我在后院挖个洞，让爱管闲事的邻居猜去吧。”查理的朋友们确信他没有发这些帖子，并怀疑导致这对情侣失踪的人是幕后黑手。他们开始在帖子下评论。
Is that what you did to Alana and the real Charlie asked one person Another added Are you hinting at what you did with them? You know it's sad that someone like you is using his Facebook page when his family and friends are worried about both him and Alana Whoever was using Charlie's account didn't answer these questions But continued to like and share posts about the missing couple that had been made by their families Some people close to Charlie suspected they knew who was behind the disturbing posts When Charlie and Alana got together he had been going through an acrimonious divorce
“这就是你对阿兰娜和真正的查理做的事吗？”一个人问道。另一个人补充道：“你在暗示你对他们做了什么吗？你知道，像你这样的人在他家人和朋友都为他和阿兰娜担心的时候使用他的Facebook页面，真是可悲。”无论谁在使用查理的账户，都没有回答这些问题。但他们继续点赞和分享家人发布的关于这对失踪情侣的帖子。一些了解查理的人怀疑他们知道谁是这些令人不安的帖子的幕后黑手。当查理和阿兰娜在一起时，他正在经历一场激烈的离婚。
Charlie and his ex-wife Nicole Nunes hadn't had a good relationship When he decided they needed to split up, Nicole was upset about it Her distress only increased when she found out about Charlie's new relationship with Alana Nicole began stalking the couple One day, Charlie returned home to their apartment to find Nicole inside He'd confided in his father about the incident and said he was too scared to take further action against Nicole He was worried that if he was too harsh, something bad would happen On Wednesday, August 31, the last day anyone had seen or heard from Charlie and Alana
查理和他的前妻妮可·努内斯的关系一直不好。当他决定两人需要分开时，妮可对此感到非常不安。当她发现查理与阿拉娜的新恋情时，她的痛苦加剧了。妮可开始跟踪这对情侣。一天，查理回到他们的公寓，发现妮可在里面。他曾向父亲吐露过这件事，并说他太害怕了，不敢对妮可采取进一步行动。他担心如果自己做得太绝，会发生不好的事情。8月31日星期三，是最后有人见到或听到查理和阿拉娜消息的日子。
Nicole made a strange Facebook post that read My beloved husband, rest in peace Charlie's loved one of his friends Charlie's loved ones noticed that the posts that started appearing on his page from Saturday, October 1 featured spelling and grammatical errors that Nicole was known to make In one comment directed at another Facebook user, the person using Charlie's account asked how the other individual knew my hubby Charlie's mother Joanne had also received text messages from Nicole stating Your son never wants to see you again. He contacted me. They're at the beach
妮可在Facebook上发布了一条奇怪的帖子，写道：“我深爱的丈夫，安息吧。”查理的朋友们注意到，从10月1日星期六开始出现在他主页上的帖子中，出现了妮可惯用的拼写和语法错误。在一条针对另一位Facebook用户的评论中，使用查理账户的人问对方是怎么认识“我丈夫”的。查理的母亲乔安妮也收到了妮可发来的短信，称：“你儿子再也不想见你了。他联系了我。他们在海滩。”
One day, a representative at the telecommunications company AT&T received a call from the lead investigator on the Charlie Carver and Alana Jones case The investigator was hoping to find out where and when Charlie's cell phone had last pinged signal towers When the AT&T employee asked for the investigator to spell out their name, the investigator failed to do so correctly They were also unable to provide a badge number Suspicious, the AT&T representative placed the investigator on hold and made a call to the police Officers confirmed that the call was not legitimate and began to trace where it had come from It was made by Charlie Carver's ex-wife Nicole Nunes Three days later, Nicole was arrested and charged with impersonating a police officer
一天，美国电话电报公司（AT&T）的一名代表接到了查理·卡弗和阿拉娜·琼斯案首席调查员的电话。调查员希望能查出查理的手机最后一次连接信号塔的时间和地点。当AT&T员工要求调查员拼写姓名时，调查员没能正确拼写出来。他们也无法提供警号。AT&T代表感到怀疑，将调查员置于保持通话状态，并拨打了警方电话。警官证实该电话并非合法，并开始追踪其来源。电话是由查理·卡弗的前妻妮可·努内斯拨打的。三天后，妮可被捕并被控冒充警官。
Yet, despite this development, investigators couldn't find any evidence connecting Nicole with the couple's disappearance Meanwhile, the case's real investigators finally had a breakthrough when they actually did receive the data from Charlie and Alana's cell phones Now, they were able to see which towers the phones had connected to in the hours and minutes before their batteries died From Wednesday, August 31, both phones had pinged a tower in the nearby town of Woodruff, which was located roughly 50 miles northeast of Anderson in neighbouring Spartanburg County Alana's phone had continued to connect to the tower up until Friday, September 2, which was two days after the couple were last seen The tower was in the vicinity of a rural 95-acre property This was significant, as Anderson County investigators had recently received a tip-off that Alana Jones was buried on a 100-acre property in Woodruff The 95-acre property was the only one in the area that fit the bill
然而，尽管有了这一进展，调查人员仍无法找到任何将妮可与这对情侣失踪联系起来的证据。与此同时，该案的真正调查人员在收到查理和阿拉娜手机的数据后，终于取得了突破。现在，他们能够看到手机在电池耗尽前的几小时和几分钟内连接了哪些信号塔。从8月31日星期三开始，两部手机都连接了附近伍德拉夫镇的一个信号塔，该镇位于安德森东北约50英里的斯帕坦堡县。阿拉娜的手机一直连接到该信号塔，直到9月2日星期五，也就是这对情侣最后一次露面后的两天。该信号塔位于一处95英亩的乡村地产附近。这一点很重要，因为安德森县的调查人员最近收到线报称，阿拉娜·琼斯被埋在伍德拉夫的一处100英亩的地产上。这处95英亩的地产是该地区唯一符合条件的地点。
Investigators flew a helicopter overhead to get a better look, but saw no sign of the couple or Charlie's white Pontiac Grand Prix Instead, they saw dense woodland and ravines as well as several small buildings There was no electricity there, just some solar panels Investigators began to wonder if they were looking at a growhouse, a term for a property used for the production of cannabis or other illicit substances As the property was privately owned, they had to obtain a search warrant to take a closer look on foot On the morning of Thursday, November 3, sheriffs deputies headed out to the rural property armed with a warrant A tall chain-link fence surrounded most of the farm with signs attached that read, warning, private property, no trespassing
调查人员驾驶直升机在上方盘旋以进行观察，但没有发现这对情侣或查理的白色庞蒂亚克大奖赛汽车的踪迹。相反，他们看到了茂密的林地、沟壑以及几座小型建筑。那里没有电，只有一些太阳能电池板。调查人员开始怀疑他们看到的是一个“种植屋”，即用于生产大麻或其他非法物质的场所。由于该地产是私有的，他们必须获得搜查令才能步行近距离查看。11月3日星期四上午，治安官副手带着搜查令前往该乡村地产。高大的铁丝网围栏环绕着农场的大部分区域，上面挂着写有“警告，私人领地，禁止入内”的牌子。
It was rare to see a fence like this on similar properties in the area A wide gravel path led from the main road into the property's entrance and snaked through the privately owned land Investigators made their way along the path Most of the property was wooded, but they observed a few buildings as they went There was a gardening shed, a workshop garage with what looked like an apartment on top, and a 30 foot long green shipping container As police meticulously combed through the woodland, they suddenly made a discovery inside a ravine A white car that was smeared with what looked like brown paint had been dumped in the sloping space Some branches and foliage had been placed on top of it, as though whoever had left the vehicle there was trying to camouflage it
在该地区的类似地产上看到这样的围栏并不常见。一条宽阔的碎石路从主路通向地产入口，并蜿蜒穿过这片私有土地。调查人员沿着小路前行。大部分地产都是林地，但他们沿途观察到几座建筑。有一个园艺棚、一个带楼上公寓的工作室车库，以及一个30英尺长的绿色集装箱。当警察仔细搜查林地时，他们突然在沟壑中有了发现。一辆涂着看起来像棕色油漆的白色汽车被丢弃在倾斜的空间里。一些树枝和叶子被放在车顶上，仿佛留下车辆的人试图对其进行伪装。
Investigators identified the car as Charlie Carver's Pontiac Grand Prix The discovery confirmed that the couple had been at the property Next, the deputies searched the buildings No one was on the premises as officers examined the garage with the first floor apartment On the walls of the upstairs loft apartment were several heavy chains with padlocks attached Next, they looked at the shed before heading towards the shipping container It was what is known as a connex box, a kind of cargo carrier that the US Army had started using during the Korean War There were five heavy padlocks on the connex box, preventing the deputies from opening it up
调查人员确认这辆车是查理·卡弗的庞蒂亚克大奖赛。这一发现证实这对情侣确实到过该地产。接下来，副手们搜查了这些建筑。当警官检查带二楼公寓的车库时，现场没有人。楼上阁楼公寓的墙上挂着几条带有挂锁的粗重铁链。接着，他们查看了棚屋，然后走向集装箱。这是一种被称为“康内克斯箱”（connex box）的货物运输箱，是美国陆军在朝鲜战争期间开始使用的一种货运载体。集装箱上有五把沉重的挂锁，阻止了副手们打开它。
Realising there must be something important inside if someone was so determined to keep it locked, the officers began trying to remove one of the locks by hitting it repeatedly with a sledgehammer For 15 minutes they tried to break it, but it wouldn't open Then, one of the deputies suddenly called out, stop She thought she could hear a banging from inside the container Her colleagues stopped and listened They heard something too, though it wasn't clear if it was coming from the woods or the container Two of the investigators made their way along the right side of the container where the noise was louder One of them knocked on the exterior steel wall
意识到如果有人如此执着地将其锁住，里面一定有重要的东西，警官们开始尝试用大锤反复敲击其中一把锁，试图将其拆除。他们尝试了15分钟，但锁没有打开。这时，其中一名副手突然喊道：“停下。”她以为自己能听到集装箱内传出敲击声。她的同事们停下来倾听。他们也听到了声音，尽管不清楚声音是来自树林还是集装箱。两名调查人员沿着集装箱的右侧走去，那里的噪音更大。其中一人敲了敲外部的钢墙。
A knock came back in reply and a voice screamed Help me, get me out of here Realising someone was inside the shipping container, the deputies felt an overwhelming sense of urgency Using a circular power saw and a crowbar they found on the property, they cut through the steel padlocks and forced open the container doors Inside was a long and totally dark hallway Using flashlights to see, they passed a tall narrow cage and some storage shelves that lined either side of the container Towards the back of the container, a woman wearing grey tracksuit pants and a black sweater was sitting on a mattress with her legs outstretched She held her hands above her head to show she was unarmed
里面传来敲击声作为回应，一个声音尖叫道：“救救我，放我出去！”意识到集装箱里有人，副手们感到一种强烈的紧迫感。他们使用在现场找到的圆盘切割机和撬棍，切断了钢制挂锁，强行打开了集装箱门。里面是一条又长又完全黑暗的走廊。他们用手电筒照明，经过了一个高而窄的笼子和一些排列在集装箱两侧的储物架。在集装箱后部，一名穿着灰色运动裤和黑色毛衣的女子坐在床垫上，双腿伸直。她把手举过头顶，表示自己没有武器。
Her wrists were handcuffed together One of her ankles was cuffed to a chain that was attached to the wall Her neck had a heavy padlocked chain around it as well, which was also attached to the wall The woman was Alana Jones Footage of the rescue was captured by the deputies Let me see your light, Brandon You can put your hand vest with us You're okay, we're here, okay?
她的手腕被手铐铐在一起。她的一只脚踝被铐在连接墙壁的铁链上。她的脖子上也套着一条沉重的挂锁铁链，同样连接在墙上。这名女子是阿拉娜·琼斯。救援过程被副手们拍摄了下来。“让我看看你的灯，布兰登。你可以把手放在我们这里。你没事了，我们在这儿，好吗？”
Jump it back Light on the roll We're getting rested over here Let's get her out of here We're getting bolt cutters, honey, don't... You got pictures of the cuffs? Nah, hold on Bolt cutters
“往后退。灯光照过来。我们在这儿休息一下。把她带出去。我们要拿断线钳，亲爱的，别……你有手铐的照片吗？不，等等。断线钳。”
There's both feet Just one It's attached to a chain from the wall and my neck's attached to the wall up here Okay Alright, we're gonna get you out of here, okay? You got a handcuff, kid I got one of them, someone's gonna call I got one of them, they're gonna call her
“两只脚都在这儿。只有一只。它连着墙上的链子，我的脖子也连在上面的墙上。”“好的，好吧，我们要把你带出去，好吗？你有手铐，孩子。我有一个，有人会打电话。我有一个，他们会叫她。”
Go over there when I get that Bolt cutters Just hit the chain right there, Bruce Just no, just right there at her hand, Brandon We'll get it off, we'll get it off here Do you know where your buddy is? Charlie Yes
“我拿到那个的时候去那边。断线钳。布鲁斯，就敲那里的链子。不，就在她手那里，布兰登。我们会把它弄掉的，我们会把它弄掉的。你知道你的伙伴在哪吗？查理。”“是的。”
He shot him Who shot him? Who didn't? Todd Kohep, Charlie Carver Three times in the chest, wrapped him in a blue tarp Put him in the bucket of the tractor Locked me down here, I've never seen him again He says he's dead and buried
“他开枪打死了他。”“谁开枪打死了他？谁没开枪？托德·科赫普，查理·卡弗。胸部开了三枪，用蓝色防水布裹住他。把他放进拖拉机的铲斗里。把我锁在这里，我再也没见过他。他说他死了，被埋了。”
Some of our bodies dead and buried out here And he says that the dogs will be ruined if they go looking Cause there's red pepper As the deputies used bolt cutters to free Alana from her restraints She told them that the man responsible for her ordeal was the owner of the property His name was Todd Kohep Alana said Kohep had shot her boyfriend Charlie three times in the chest Then wrapped his body in a blue tarp
“我们的一些尸体死后被埋在这里。他说如果狗去搜寻，它们就会被毁掉，因为有红辣椒。”当副手们用断线钳解开阿拉娜的束缚时，她告诉他们，对她的苦难负责的人是该地产的主人。他的名字叫托德·科赫普。阿拉娜说科赫普朝她的男友查理的胸部开了三枪，然后用蓝色防水布裹住了他的尸体。
Using a tractor, he'd moved Charlie to another location of the property and buried him Alana never saw Charlie again Kohep had told Alana he had other bodies hidden on the property as well He'd scattered red peppers around, which he thought would mask the scent of human remains from police dogs Deputies let Alana out of the container and into an ambulance So she could be taken to a hospital for treatment As she was being transported to the hospital, investigators continued to question her Alana Jones had met Todd Kohep through a mutual friend in around 2011
他用拖拉机把查理转移到地产的另一个位置并埋葬了。阿拉娜再也没见过查理。科赫普告诉阿拉娜，他在地产上还藏有其他尸体。他撒了红辣椒，他认为这能掩盖人类遗骸的气味，防止警犬发现。副手们将阿拉娜带出集装箱并送上救护车，以便她能被送往医院接受治疗。在被送往医院的过程中，调查人员继续询问她。阿拉娜·琼斯是在2011年左右通过共同的朋友认识托德·科赫普的。
The two became Facebook friends and occasionally stayed in touch Eventually, Alana started cleaning some of the properties listed by Kohep's agency for extra cash On Wednesday, August 31, she and Charlie had gone to the rural property after Kohep offered to pay them to clear some brush When they arrived, he'd given them hedge clippers and a bottle of water before pointing out the areas that needed tidying Kohep then went into the garage to get something When he returned, he was holding a gun Before the couple could register what was going on, Kohep shot and killed Charlie As Alana had stared down at her boyfriend's body in shock, Kohep grabbed her from behind, handcuffed her and bound her ankles
两人成了Facebook好友，偶尔保持联系。最终，阿拉娜开始清理科赫普代理机构挂牌的一些房产以赚取额外现金。8月31日星期三，她和查理来到这处乡村地产，因为科赫普提出付钱让他们清理一些灌木。当他们到达时，他给了他们树篱剪和一瓶水，然后指出了需要清理的区域。科赫普随后走进车库去拿东西。当他回来时，手里拿着一把枪。在两人还没反应过来发生了什么之前，科赫普开枪打死了查理。当阿拉娜震惊地盯着男友的尸体时，科赫普从背后抓住她，给她戴上手铐并绑住了她的脚踝。
He apologized about killing Charlie but said he had to let Alana know he was serious Kohep made her watch as he wrapped Charlie's body in the tarp Then he led her to the storage container where she was forced to stay for the next two months Alana said she was kept chained up almost the entire time Kohep would visit her at the property between 1 and 3 p.m. every day and move her from the shipping container to the apartment Then he would beat her and quote, make me do whatever he wanted sexually before transferring her back to the container He'd leave for a while before returning between 5 and 7 p.m. and repeating the process all over again If Alana said no to any sex acts Kohep wanted to do, he wouldn't physically force her because he claimed he didn't believe in rape
他为杀害查理道歉，但表示他必须让阿拉娜知道他是认真的。科赫普强迫她看着他用防水布裹住查理的尸体。然后他把她带到储物集装箱，她被迫在那里待了接下来的两个月。阿拉娜说她几乎一直被锁着。科赫普每天下午1点到3点之间会去地产看她，并把她从集装箱转移到公寓。然后他会殴打她，并引用他的话，“强迫我做任何他想做的性行为”，然后再把她送回集装箱。他会离开一会儿，然后在下午5点到7点之间回来，重复整个过程。如果阿拉娜拒绝科赫普想做的任何性行为，他不会进行身体上的强迫，因为他声称他不相信强奸。
But Alana said he made it very well known why she was there and she knew that if she didn't submit to his demands, he would shoot her too Sometimes Kohep would let Alana walk around outside for a little bit He liked to show her the makeshift grave where he had buried Charlie's body A second empty grave lay next to it Kohep told Alana if she ran away, she would end up there too Kohep said Alana was beautiful and that's why he'd chosen her He reassured her that one day Stockholm syndrome would kick in and she would be happy living with him too He would build a special house with a soundproof room where she would be kept permanently
但阿拉娜说，他非常明确地让她知道她为什么在那里，她知道如果她不服从他的要求，他也会开枪打死她。有时科赫普会让阿拉娜在外面走动一会儿。他喜欢向她展示他埋葬查理尸体的临时坟墓。旁边还有一个空的坟墓。科赫普告诉阿拉娜，如果她逃跑，她也会落得同样的下场。科赫普说阿拉娜很漂亮，这就是他选择她的原因。他向她保证，总有一天斯德哥尔摩综合征会发作，她也会乐于和他生活在一起。他会盖一栋带隔音室的特殊房子，让她永久留在那里。
Kohep had bragged to Alana that he was a serial killer and a mass murderer He claimed that his victims numbered in the high two digits but he planned to kill more because he dreamed of taking hundreds of lives Todd Kohep had always been a troubled child After his parents divorced in 1973 when he was two, he was raised by his mother Regina in South Carolina Regina noticed how he struggled to play with his peers at preschool Often he would just sit in a corner The only way he seemed capable of interacting with them was in an angry manner As he grew older, his behavior worsened
科赫普曾向阿拉娜吹嘘自己是一名连环杀手和大规模杀人犯。他声称他的受害者人数达到两位数的高位，但他计划杀更多人，因为他梦想夺走数百人的生命。托德·科赫普一直是一个有问题的孩子。1973年父母离婚时他才两岁，之后由母亲雷吉娜在南卡罗来纳州抚养长大。雷吉娜注意到他在幼儿园时很难与同龄人玩耍。他经常只是坐在角落里。他似乎唯一能与他们互动的方式就是愤怒。随着年龄增长，他的行为变得更糟。
Kohep would deliberately damage other students' work and was kicked out of the Boy Scouts for repeatedly misbehaving When he asked his mother and stepfather for a pet gerbil, they told him no as he already had a goldfish Kohep responded by pouring Clorox bleach into the fish tank, which his parents thought he did deliberately to kill the fish Kohep would always insist he'd just been cleaning the tank and didn't understand that bleach was toxic Another time, he was reported to have shot at a dog with a BB gun By the time Kohep was nine years old, his reputation for having an explosive temper and fixation with sexual content was cemented When people did something he didn't like, he lashed out Once, when his mother bought him a new set of bedroom furniture, he destroyed it all with a claw hammer
科赫普会故意破坏其他学生的作业，并因反复表现不佳而被童子军开除。当他向母亲和继父要一只沙鼠作为宠物时，他们拒绝了，因为他已经有一条金鱼了。科赫普的反应是将漂白剂倒入鱼缸，他的父母认为他是故意杀死鱼的。科赫普总是坚持说他只是在清理鱼缸，不明白漂白剂是有毒的。还有一次，据报道他用气枪射击了一只狗。到科赫普九岁时，他脾气暴躁和对性内容痴迷的名声已经确立。当人们做他不喜欢的动作时，他会猛烈抨击。有一次，当母亲给他买了一套新卧室家具时，他用羊角锤把它们全毁了。
Another time, he attacked a girl on his school bus after she said something that made him angry and stabbed her in the leg His mother Regina sent him to therapy and a mental health hospital, but his behavior didn't improve Kohep hated his stepfather and repeatedly asked if he could go and live with his biological father in Arizona He spent a summer with his father at age 12 after not having seen him in eight years Regina began to wonder if her son's issues were stemming from not knowing his dad When Kohep was in his early teens, Regina finally caved and allowed him to move to Arizona On the evening of Tuesday, November 25, 1986, 14-year-old Katie was at home in Tempe, Arizona, babysitting her two younger siblings Her five-year-old brother and three-year-old sister were both sleeping, so it was an easy job
还有一次，他在校车上攻击了一名女孩，因为她说的话让他生气，他刺伤了她的腿。他的母亲雷吉娜送他去接受治疗和进入心理健康医院，但他的行为没有改善。科赫普讨厌他的继父，并反复询问是否可以去亚利桑那州和亲生父亲住在一起。12岁那年，在八年没见父亲后，他与父亲度过了一个夏天。雷吉娜开始怀疑儿子的心理问题是否源于不了解父亲。科赫普十几岁出头时，雷吉娜终于妥协，允许他搬到亚利桑那州。1986年11月25日星期二晚上，14岁的凯蒂在亚利桑那州坦佩的家中照顾她的两个年幼的弟弟妹妹。她五岁的弟弟和三岁的妹妹都在睡觉，所以这是一份轻松的工作。
Katie was sitting on a love seat studying when the doorbell rang She answered it and found 15-year-old Todd Kohep, who lived three doors down, standing on her doorstep He explained that another boy who Katie had a crush on was around the corner and wanted to talk to her, but Katie refused to leave She explained that she was babysitting and shut the front door Yet Kohep wouldn't leave After repeatedly trying to coax Katie outside, he went around the back of her house to the rear door and said, just come out Hoping that if she did as he asked he would finally leave, Katie stepped outside Kohep pulled out a gun and held it to her head, stating, you're coming with me
凯蒂正坐在沙发上学习时，门铃响了。她去开门，发现住在三个门外的15岁托德·科赫普站在门口。他解释说，凯蒂暗恋的另一个男孩就在拐角处，想和她谈谈，但凯蒂拒绝离开。她解释说她在照顾孩子，并关上了前门。然而科赫普没有离开。在反复试图哄骗凯蒂出去后，他绕到她家后门说：“出来吧。”凯蒂心想如果她照他说的做，他最终会离开，于是她走了出去。科赫普掏出一把枪抵住她的头，说道：“你跟我走。”
At gunpoint, he forced her out of her backyard and into an alley that ran behind the row of houses Katie didn't even have shoes on and could feel stones and broken glass pressing into her bare feet Angry and terrified, she suddenly fought back, grabbing the barrel of the gun In response, Kohep pulled the trigger The gun misfired If it had gone off, the bullet would have struck Katie in the head Realising Kohep wouldn't hesitate to kill her, Katie didn't fight back again At Kohep's urging, she walked into his home where he was staying alone while his father was away on a business trip
在枪口下，他强迫她离开后院，进入房屋后排的一条小巷。凯蒂甚至没穿鞋，能感觉到石头和碎玻璃压在赤脚上。愤怒和恐惧中，她突然反抗，抓住了枪管。作为回应，科赫普扣动了扳机。枪卡壳了。如果枪响了，子弹会击中凯蒂的头部。意识到科赫普会毫不犹豫地杀死她，凯蒂没有再反抗。在科赫普的催促下，她走进他的家，他父亲出差期间他独自住在这里。
Kohep forced Katie into his bedroom, then bound her hands with rope and put duct tape over her mouth He held a knife to her throat and raped her Back at Katie's house, her little brother woke up and was scared to find his sister missing The five-year-old boy called 911 and soon police and their parents arrived at the property As they were gathered inside, Katie appeared at the back door Kohep had seen the police car lights from his bedroom window and panicked Katie had begged to be allowed to leave, saying she would just tell the police they'd been out looking for a missing dog Kohep eventually agreed, but said that if she said anything about what really happened, he would murder her whole family
科赫普强迫凯蒂进入卧室，然后用绳子绑住她的手，并用胶带封住她的嘴。他用刀抵住她的喉咙并强奸了她。回到凯蒂家，她的小弟弟醒了，发现姐姐失踪了，感到很害怕。这个五岁的男孩拨打了911，很快警察和他们的父母赶到了现场。当他们聚集在屋内时，凯蒂出现在后门。科赫普从卧室窗户看到了警车灯光，感到恐慌。凯蒂恳求让他离开，说她会告诉警察他们只是出去找丢失的狗。科赫普最终同意了，但说如果她说出真相，他会杀掉她全家。
Although Katie initially told her parents and the police that she'd been looking for a dog, they could see from her demeanor that something terrible had happened After some coaxing, Katie began to cry and told the truth Officers immediately went to Kohep's house to arrest him Kohep answered the door with a .22 caliber rifle behind his back Pulling out her own handgun, an officer demanded he leave the house immediately or she would shoot him Kohep did as he was told, then asked I just need to know how much I am going to get for this Although he was only 15, Kohep was charged as an adult
虽然凯蒂最初告诉父母和警察她是在找狗，但他们从她的神态中看出发生了可怕的事情。在一番劝说后，凯蒂开始哭泣并说出了真相。警官们立即前往科赫普家逮捕他。科赫普开门时，背后藏着一支.22口径步枪。一名警官掏出自己的手枪，要求他立即离开房子，否则她会开枪。科赫普照做了，然后问：“我只需要知道我会因为这个被判多久。”尽管他只有15岁，但科赫普被作为成年人起诉。
He agreed to plead guilty to kidnapping if the sexual assault charge was dropped to avoid having to go to trial After a court ordered psychological assessment, Kohep was diagnosed with borderline personality disorder He said that he'd attacked Katie because he was angry and wanted to rebel against his often absent father Kohep's mother Regina sent a letter requesting leniency in sentencing, writing They don't stop to think that he even walked the girl home. Does that sound like a dangerous criminal? Despite her request, the judge gave Kohep 15 years to be served in an adult prison in Arizona The adult probation officer noted that Todd Kohep was, quote The type of individual, one with little or no conscience, who presents the greatest risk to the community
他同意承认绑架罪，如果性侵犯罪名被撤销，以避免接受审判。经过法院下令的心理评估，科赫普被诊断出患有边缘性人格障碍。他说他攻击凯蒂是因为他很生气，想反抗他经常缺席的父亲。科赫普的母亲雷吉娜写了一封信请求减刑，写道：“他们没有停下来想一想，他甚至把那个女孩送回了家。这听起来像是一个危险的罪犯吗？”尽管她提出了请求，法官还是判处科赫普15年监禁，在亚利桑那州的成人监狱服刑。成人缓刑官指出，托德·科赫普是“那种几乎没有良知，对社区构成最大风险的个人”。
In November 2001, Kohep was released from prison at the age of 30 It wasn't long before he moved back to South Carolina Although he had to add his name to the state's sex offender registry, Kohep also said about rebuilding his life He worked as a graphic designer using vocational training he'd completed in prison and obtained a business degree from the University of South Carolina Upstate In 2006, he applied for a South Carolina real estate license The application didn't require a criminal background check, but applicants did have to note any convictions themselves Kohep explained away his felony conviction as being due to a heated breakup he'd had with his girlfriend During the argument, Kohep's dog escaped and the two teenagers had to go looking for it
2001年11月，科赫普在30岁时获释。没过多久，他就搬回了南卡罗来纳州。虽然他必须将自己的名字加入该州的性犯罪者登记册，但科赫普也谈到了重建生活。他利用在监狱完成的职业培训担任平面设计师，并获得了南卡罗来纳大学上州分校的商业学位。2006年，他申请了南卡罗来纳州的房地产执照。申请不需要犯罪背景调查，但申请人必须自行注明任何定罪。科赫普将他的重罪定罪解释为与女友激烈分手所致。在争吵中，科赫普的狗跑了，两个青少年不得不去寻找它。
Meanwhile, his girlfriend's parents hadn't known where their daughter was and called the police I was charged with the felony of kidnapping due to the fact that I did have a firearm on me, regardless that she didn't know about it And I had told her not to move while we talked this out, Kohep wrote At this time, Arizona was coming down very hard on minors and anything to do with firearms due to the heavy gang activity out there And I received a sentence of 15 years, for which I served every day, no parole required His application was approved and by 2008, Kohep was a successful real estate agent During the following year, he registered his own company, Todd Kohep and associates The business grew with about a dozen agents on staff
与此同时，他女友的父母不知道女儿在哪里，于是报了警。“我被控绑架重罪，因为我身上确实带着枪，尽管她不知道。我告诉她在我们谈清楚之前不要动，”科赫普写道。“当时，亚利桑那州对未成年人和任何与枪支有关的事情打击非常严厉，因为那里有严重的帮派活动。我被判了15年监禁，我服满了每一天，不需要假释。”他的申请获得批准，到2008年，科赫普成为了一名成功的房地产经纪人。第二年，他注册了自己的公司，托德·科赫普联合公司。业务不断增长，拥有十几名员工。
Kohep began driving BMWs and owned multiple properties, two cars and a motorbike In 2013, he achieved a childhood dream by obtaining his pilot's license His life appeared to be successful But there were cracks in the facade Kohep was known to boast about his wealth and how he was an expert with firearms He openly discussed his sex offender status while lying about how he'd received it Some potential clients instinctively found him creepy and off-putting At work, he was known for openly watching pornography in his office
科赫普开始驾驶宝马，拥有多处房产、两辆汽车和一辆摩托车。2013年，他通过获得飞行员执照实现了童年的梦想。他的生活看起来很成功。但外表下有裂痕。科赫普以吹嘘自己的财富和他是枪支专家而闻名。他公开讨论自己的性犯罪者身份，同时撒谎说他是如何获得的。一些潜在客户本能地觉得他令人毛骨悚然和反感。在工作中，他以在办公室公开观看色情片而闻名。
He had a dark sense of humour and talked about how he chased people off his property while wearing night vision goggles and carrying guns equipped with silencers According to Kohep, he owned an arsenal of weapons, even though in South Carolina it is illegal for violent felons to own firearms In the close-knit neighborhood where he lived, Kohep kept to himself In 2014, he bought the sprawling 95-acre property in Woodruff where Alana Jones would be found two years later Kohep paid $80,000 to install an expansive chain-link fence and installed deer cameras and bear traps throughout the property These weren't intended to deter animals, but humans An Amazon account in Toge Kohep's name revealed that around the same time he'd bought padlocks, knives, targets, tactical gear and gun accessories He often left reviews for these items that hinted at how he intended to use them
他有一种黑暗的幽默感，谈论他如何戴着夜视镜、携带装有消音器的枪支将人赶出他的地产。据科赫普说，他拥有一个武器库，尽管在南卡罗来纳州，暴力重罪犯拥有枪支是非法的。在他居住的紧密社区里，科赫普独来独往。2014年，他买下了伍德拉夫那处95英亩的广阔地产，两年后阿拉娜·琼斯就在那里被发现。科赫普支付了8万美元安装了一道宽阔的铁丝网围栏，并在整个地产上安装了鹿用摄像头和捕熊器。这些不是为了威慑动物，而是为了威慑人类。一个以托德·科赫普名义注册的亚马逊账户显示，大约在同一时间，他购买了挂锁、刀具、靶子、战术装备和枪支配件。他经常为这些物品留下评论，暗示他打算如何使用它们。
When reviewing a knife, he wrote Haven't stabbed anyone yet, but I am keeping the dream alive and when I do, it will be with a quality tool like this For a padlock, he wrote Works great. Also, if someone talks back, go old-school on them by putting this in a sock and beating them They will not appreciate the hardened steel like you will The review for another set of padlocks made a reference similar to one someone had posted on Charlie Carver's Facebook page while posing as him Now my locks have locks. Places Hotel California now When investigators traced Alana's cell phone to the vicinity of the rural property owned by Kohep, they'd applied for his cell phone data too
在评论一把刀时，他写道：“还没刺过人，但我会让梦想成真，当我这样做时，我会用像这样高质量的工具。”对于一把挂锁，他写道：“效果很好。另外，如果有人顶嘴，把这个放进袜子里打他们，用老派的方式对付他们。他们不会像你一样欣赏硬化钢。”另一套挂锁的评论引用了有人在查理·卡弗的Facebook页面上冒充他时发布的内容：“现在我的锁有了锁。这里是加州旅馆。”当调查人员将阿拉娜的手机追踪到科赫普拥有的乡村地产附近时，他们也申请了他的手机数据。
They saw that it had been in the same area repeatedly during the two months that Alana and Charlie were missing This was enough for a search warrant to be granted While one team of investigators went to the rural property, another group headed to the house where Kohep lived just eight miles away Kohep answered the front door to his red brick home dressed in a blue t-shirt and shorts Deputies informed him that they had information indicating he was the last person to have seen missing couple Alana Jones and Charlie Carver and had a search warrant for his other property Kohep didn't seem bothered and sat on a chair in his house's foyer while making small talk with the investigators One deputy received a call and went outside to take it It was a colleague who was at Kohep's rural property informing him how they'd found Alana chained up in a storage container
他们看到在阿拉娜和查理失踪的两个月里，他的手机多次出现在同一区域。这足以获得搜查令。当一组调查人员前往乡村地产时，另一组前往科赫普居住的房子，那里距离只有八英里。科赫普穿着蓝色T恤和短裤在红砖房门口应门。副手们通知他，他们有信息表明他是最后见到失踪情侣阿拉娜·琼斯和查理·卡弗的人，并持有搜查令搜查他的另一处房产。科赫普似乎并不在意，坐在他家门厅的椅子上，与调查人员闲聊。一名副手接到电话，走到外面去接。是科赫普乡村地产的一名同事，告诉他他们是如何发现阿拉娜被锁在储物集装箱里的。
The deputy went back inside and confronted Kohep with this information Kohep responded by tilting his head to one side and saying Excuse me? The deputy continued She has told us that you shot and killed Charlie Kohep was informed that he was being arrested When asked where Charlie's body was and why he had kidnapped Alana, Kohep replied I want an attorney
副手回到屋内，用这个信息与科赫普对质。科赫普歪着头回答说：“你说什么？”副手继续说：“她告诉我们你开枪打死了查理。”科赫普被告知他被捕了。当被问及查理的尸体在哪里以及为什么要绑架阿拉娜时，科赫普回答说：“我要找律师。”
Probably a good thing the deputy retorted before having Kohep put in the back of a police vehicle It didn't take authorities long to recover Charlie Carver's body from a shallow grave on the property Once Todd Kohep learned the body had been found, he agreed to make a full confession with some conditions He wanted to talk to his mother before making any more statements and asked investigators to pass along a special picture to her He also wanted to transfer some money to the daughter of a friend to help pay her college tuition The investigators agreed to these terms Kohep said he'd targeted Alana and Charlie because he was angry with Alana He confirmed things she had already told investigators
“这可能是件好事，”副手反驳道，然后让科赫普坐进警车后座。当局没花多久就从地产的一个浅坟中找回了查理·卡弗的尸体。一旦托德·科赫普得知尸体已被发现，他同意在某些条件下做出全面供述。他想在发表更多声明前与母亲交谈，并要求调查人员转交一张特别的照片给她。他还想把一些钱转给一位朋友的女儿，以帮助支付她的大学学费。调查人员同意了这些条款。科赫普说他针对阿拉娜和查理是因为他生阿拉娜的气。他证实了她已经告诉调查人员的事情。
When they asked if the empty, freshly dug grave next to Charlie's had been intended for Alana, he said yes Adding, she came real close Really, asked one investigator She has no idea, Kohep replied More than once Kohep agreed to take investigators to the place on his property where he'd buried two more bodies Both were so badly decomposed that they had to be identified from their tattoos and other identifying features They were married couple Johnny and Megan Coxie who'd lived in Spartanburg and had a son together
当他们问查理旁边那个空的、刚挖好的坟墓是否是为阿拉娜准备的时，他说：“是的。”并补充道：“她离得很近。”“真的吗？”一名调查人员问。“她根本不知道，”科赫普回答。不止一次，科赫普同意带调查人员去他地产上埋葬另外两具尸体的地方。两具尸体都已严重腐烂，必须通过纹身和其他识别特征来确认身份。他们是已婚夫妇约翰尼和梅根·考克西，他们曾住在斯帕坦堡，并育有一个儿子。
26-year-old Megan had a history of heroin usage and was charged with neglect in late 2015 when her child tested positive for the drug Both she and Johnny were placed in jail until Megan asked her mother to bond her out so she could work a job She wanted to fix her life and provide for her family Her mother agreed, but never heard from Megan again Both she and Johnny were reported missing on Tuesday December 22, 2015 With few leads, the case never really got off the ground It turned out that Kohep had met 26-year-old Megan at a waffle house where she waited tables and he liked to lurk He gained a reputation for leaving generous tips and inviting waitresses back to his home
26岁的梅根有海洛因使用史，2015年底因孩子药物检测呈阳性而被控疏忽照顾。她和约翰尼都被关进监狱，直到梅根要求母亲保释她出来，以便她能找份工作。她想改善生活并供养家庭。她母亲同意了，但再也没有梅根的消息。她和约翰尼于2015年12月22日星期二被报告失踪。由于线索很少，案件从未真正取得进展。事实证明，科赫普是在一家华夫饼屋遇到26岁的梅根的，她在那里当服务员，而他喜欢在那里徘徊。他以给小费大方并邀请女服务员去他家而闻名。
Kohep had creeped out most of the female staff so much that one of the male cooks started taking his orders instead Kohep had offered Megan money to clean his property. This was the job she had told her mother about Kohep told the deputies that Johnny had jumped him with a knife trying to rob him once they were out at the property He'd killed Johnny in self-defense by shooting him in the chest Kohep began to panic as he knew he wasn't allowed to own guns due to his criminal record and also had illegal drugs on the property Unsure of what to do with Megan, he put her in the shipping container Kohep claimed that sometimes Megan was calm, but other times she went, quote, that shit crazy He insisted that he hadn't sexually assaulted Megan, but investigators were unconvinced
科赫普让大多数女性员工感到毛骨悚然，以至于其中一名男厨师开始接替他的订单。科赫普曾提出给梅根钱让她清理他的地产。这就是她告诉母亲的工作。科赫普告诉副手，约翰尼在地产上用刀袭击他，试图抢劫他。他通过射击他的胸部以自卫杀死了约翰尼。科赫普开始恐慌，因为他知道由于犯罪记录，他不允许拥有枪支，而且地产上还有非法毒品。不知道该拿梅根怎么办，他把她关进了集装箱。科赫普声称有时梅根很冷静，但有时她会“疯了”。他坚持说他没有性侵梅根，但调查人员并不相信。
Kohep said that after five or six days he struck a deal with Megan He would give her $4000 and drive her to Tennessee, then they would go their separate ways He said that Megan was happy as hell with this arrangement, but when Kohep checked on her the next day, she tried to burn down the shipping container and was, quote, going nuts He walked her outside of the container, then shot her in the back of the head Kohep assured the investigators that the similarities between the attacks against the two couples were purely coincidental The land was supposed to be my sanctuary, not my killing field, he laughed Yet, it quickly became clear that Kohep's violent acts were not limited to his rural property in Woodruff Following Alana Jones' rescue from the shipping container, she told a police officer that Kohep had bragged about being a serial killer and mass murderer
科赫普说，五六天后，他与梅根达成了一项协议。他会给她4000美元并开车送她去田纳西州，然后他们分道扬镳。他说梅根对这个安排非常高兴，但当科赫普第二天去看她时，她试图烧毁集装箱，并且“疯了”。他把她带出集装箱，然后朝她的后脑勺开了一枪。科赫普向调查人员保证，针对这两对情侣的袭击之间的相似之处纯属巧合。“这片土地本应是我的避难所，而不是我的杀戮场，”他笑着说。然而，很快就很清楚，科赫普的暴力行为并不局限于他在伍德拉夫的乡村地产。在阿拉娜·琼斯从集装箱获救后，她告诉一名警官，科赫普曾吹嘘自己是一名连环杀手和大规模杀人犯。
Then she added, he also told me that a few years back, he walked into a bike shop in Anderson and shot four people Although Alana thought the shop was in Anderson and not Chesney, there was little doubt what case Kohep had been referring to The massacre at Superbike Motorsports was the most notorious cold case in Spartanburg County, the same county where Kohep had lived and committed his other crimes Kohep also bore an uncanny resemblance to the second sketch that had been made of the suspect, with the same downturned mouth and squinting eyes Investigators asked Kohep to walk them through his dealings with the store In 2003, Todd Kohep was in his early 30s and two years out of prison He was studying at Greenville Technical College and that same year he also bought a motorcycle from Superbike Motorsports Kohep soon realized that the bike was too big for an inexperienced motorcyclist like him
然后她补充说：“他还告诉我，几年前，他走进安德森的一家自行车店，枪杀了四个人。”虽然阿拉娜认为商店在安德森而不是切斯尼，但毫无疑问科赫普指的是哪个案件。超级摩托车赛车运动（Superbike Motorsports）的大屠杀是斯帕坦堡县最臭名昭著的悬案，这也是科赫普居住并犯下其他罪行的县。科赫普与为嫌疑人制作的第二张素描惊人地相似，有着同样的下垂嘴和眯眯眼。调查人员要求科赫普带他们回顾他与该店的往来。2003年，托德·科赫普30岁出头，出狱两年。他当时在格林维尔技术学院学习，同年他还从超级摩托车赛车运动店买了一辆摩托车。科赫普很快意识到这辆车对于像他这样的新手摩托车手来说太大了。
He'd only owned it for two weeks when it was stolen from out the front of the apartment complex where he lived Kohep received an insurance payout and decided to buy another bike He started visiting Superbike Motorsports again to look at different models After hearing Kohep planned to replace his stolen bike, the manager Brian Lucas said to him Great, now we'll have another one to go pick up Kohep interpreted this to mean that the store was behind the theft of his first bike He left the store but continued to stew about what Brian had said Kohep became angrier and angrier
他只拥有了两个星期，车就在他居住的公寓大楼前被偷了。科赫普获得了保险赔付，并决定再买一辆车。他开始再次访问超级摩托车赛车运动店查看不同型号。在听说科赫普计划更换被盗的摩托车后，经理布莱恩·卢卡斯对他说：“太好了，现在我们又有车要去取了。”科赫普将其解读为商店是盗窃他第一辆车的幕后黑手。他离开了商店，但继续对布莱恩说的话耿耿于怀。科赫普变得越来越愤怒。
He continued to visit Superbike Motorsports where he would sit on the store's bikes and eavesdrop on Scott Ponder and Brian Lucas Quote, basically talk trash Eventually, Kohep decided to purchase a Beretta 9mm pistol and went back to the store one final time on the afternoon of Thursday, November 6, 2003 He inspected some bikes while scoping out the store and trying to ensure that Scott, Brian and mechanic Chris Sherbert were all there He'd deliberately chosen a quiet time of day as he wanted no other customers around Quote, collateral damage is not cool Kohep wasn't thrilled when Scott's mother Beverly Guy arrived, telling investigators I prefer not to shoot women if I can
他继续访问超级摩托车赛车运动店，坐在店里的摩托车上，偷听斯科特·庞德和布莱恩·卢卡斯的谈话。引用他的话，“基本上是在说垃圾话。”最终，科赫普决定购买一把贝雷塔9毫米手枪，并于2003年11月6日星期四下午最后一次回到店里。他检查了一些摩托车，同时观察商店，并试图确保斯科特、布莱恩和机械师克里斯·谢伯特都在那里。他特意选择了一天中安静的时间，因为他不希望有其他顾客在场。“附带损害并不酷，”他说。当斯科特的母亲贝弗利·盖伊到达时，科赫普并不高兴，他告诉调查人员：“如果可以的话，我更愿意不射杀女性。”
But her presence didn't deter him and finally, when all four store employees were the only other people in the building, Kohep told them he wanted to buy a particular bike Scott and Brian began sorting out the paperwork while Chris Sherbert took the motorcycle out the back to prep it After a few minutes, Kohep followed him to the mechanics area He pulled out his pistol and shot Chris twice in the chest Chris fell to the ground and lay still Kohep then headed towards the front of the building, just as Scott, Brian and Beverly all moved to the mechanics area to investigate the sound they'd just heard The three of them stood in front of Kohep As Beverly was the closest, he shot her two or three times in the chest
但她的出现并没有阻止他，最终，当所有四名店员是楼里仅有的其他人时，科赫普告诉他们他想买一辆特定的摩托车。斯科特和布莱恩开始整理文书工作，而克里斯·谢伯特把摩托车带到后面准备。几分钟后，科赫普跟着他到了机械区。他掏出手枪，朝克里斯的胸部开了两枪。克里斯倒在地上，一动不动。科赫普随后朝大楼前部走去，正好斯科特、布莱恩和贝弗利都移动到机械区调查他们刚刚听到的声音。他们三人站在科赫普面前。由于贝弗利离得最近，他朝她的胸部开了两三枪。
As she fell, Scott and Brian ran for the door As they ran, Kohep shot Brian in the back, then aimed at Scott as he was reaching the parking lot After all four victims had fallen, Kohep went to each body and shot them in the forehead This was a detail investigators had withheld from the press and convinced them that Kohep was telling the truth A check would reveal his name had also been in the store's customer database that the original investigators had received On the 10th anniversary of the murders, Kohep had received one of the many letters that were sent out to superbike customers, asking if he knew anything about the crime He had never replied Kohep described the slayings as being like playing a video game and used military style language to detail each action
当她倒下时，斯科特和布莱恩跑向门口。当他们跑时，科赫普朝布莱恩的背部开枪，然后瞄准了正在到达停车场的斯科特。在所有四名受害者倒下后，科赫普走到每具尸体前，朝他们的前额开枪。这是一个调查人员对媒体隐瞒的细节，这让他们相信科赫普说的是实话。检查显示他的名字也出现在原始调查人员收到的商店客户数据库中。在谋杀案发生10周年之际，科赫普收到了许多寄给超级摩托车客户的信件之一，询问他是否知道有关犯罪的任何信息。他从未回复。科赫普将杀戮描述为像玩电子游戏，并使用军事术语详细说明了每一个动作。
He boasted about how quick the mass shooting had been, telling the interviewing detectives I cleared that building in under 30 seconds. I'm sorry, but you guys would have been proud Scott, Brian and Beverly's loved ones were shocked to hear the case had finally been solved 13 years later Tom Lucas, the father of Brian Lucas had become an advocate for families in the area who lived with unsolved crimes He had been gathered with some of them the day before Kohep confessed and had sensed something powerful at the time When Tom and his wife Lorraine received a call the following day to say the perpetrator was in custody, he couldn't believe it Lorraine would later say she went completely numb Scott Ponder's wife Melissa Brackman was phoned by a detective who she had a good relationship with
他吹嘘那场大规模枪击事件发生得有多快，并告诉负责审讯的侦探：“我在不到30秒的时间内就清理了那栋大楼。抱歉，但你们会为我感到骄傲的。”斯科特、布莱恩和贝弗利的亲人们在13年后得知案件终于告破时感到震惊。布莱恩·卢卡斯的父亲汤姆·卢卡斯成为了当地那些生活在未破悬案阴影下的家庭的倡导者。在科尔普认罪的前一天，他曾与其中一些人聚在一起，当时就感觉到了一种强大的力量。当汤姆和妻子洛林第二天接到电话得知凶手已被拘留时，他简直不敢相信。洛林后来形容自己当时完全麻木了。斯科特·庞德的妻子梅丽莎·布拉克曼接到了她关系很好的侦探打来的电话。
He instructed her to sit down, then said, we got him Melissa began to cry She had made peace with the fact that she might never know who killed her husband and the father of her son Scotty, who was now nearly 13 years old Terry Guy, Beverly's husband and Scott's stepfather was also relieved, but at the same time he empathized with Kohep's family Quote My emotions are running from joy to crying, even feeling sorry for the family of Kohep I feel for them There was less relief for the families of Charlie Carver, Johnny Coxie and Megan Coxie, who were only just learning that their loved ones were dead
他让她坐下，然后说：“我们抓住他了。”梅丽莎开始哭泣。她已经接受了可能永远不知道是谁杀害了她丈夫以及她儿子斯科蒂父亲的事实，而斯科蒂现在已经快13岁了。贝弗利的丈夫、斯科特的继父特里·盖伊也感到如释重负，但同时他也对科尔普的家人表示同情。引用：“我的情绪在喜悦和哭泣之间徘徊，甚至为科尔普的家人感到难过。我同情他们。”对于查理·卡弗、约翰尼·考克西和梅根·考克西的家人来说，这种解脱感较少，因为他们才刚刚得知亲人已经遇害的消息。
A close friend of Johnny Coxie's mother, Cindy, issued a statement on her behalf stating Cindy came about a year ago requesting prayer for her son Johnny and his wife Megan, who were missing We have been praying for about a year now that they would be found and we would know what happened Today they received the news The family is in shock, grieving and are not comfortable talking to anyone at this time They have asked for people to please try and understand and give them time to heal Todd Kohep agreed to plead guilty to seven counts of murder, two kidnapping charges and one count of criminal sexual assault In exchange for his plea, prosecutors took the death penalty off the table
约翰尼·考克西母亲辛迪的一位密友代表她发表了一份声明，称：“辛迪大约在一年前请求大家为她失踪的儿子约翰尼和儿媳梅根祈祷。我们祈祷了大约一年，希望他们能被找到，并了解发生了什么。今天他们收到了消息。家人处于震惊和悲痛之中，目前不愿与任何人交谈。他们请求大家理解并给他们时间疗伤。”托德·科尔普同意对七项谋杀罪、两项绑架罪和一项刑事性侵犯罪认罪。作为认罪的交换，检察官放弃了死刑诉求。
On Friday, May 26, 2017, Kohep was sentenced to seven consecutive life sentences without the possibility of parole Surviving victim Alana Jones did not attend due to an ongoing struggle with post-traumatic stress disorder, but the courtroom was packed with family members of those who'd been killed They addressed him in turn In an emotional voice, Scott Ponder's wife Melissa Brackman stated I have missed motorcycle riding on the back of his bike, having him there to rub my pregnant belly, to feel Scott Jr. kick and take him bike riding, motorcycle riding I lost so much Her son Scott Jr., who had just finished seventh grade, said I'm always going to wonder what it would have been like if my dad was here
2017年5月26日星期五，科尔普被判处七个连续终身监禁，且不得假释。幸存受害者阿兰娜·琼斯因长期受创伤后应激障碍困扰而未出席，但法庭挤满了遇难者的家属。他们轮流向他陈述。斯科特·庞德的妻子梅丽莎·布拉克曼声音颤抖地说：“我怀念坐在他摩托车后座骑行的日子，怀念他抚摸我怀孕的肚子、感受小斯科特踢动，并带他去骑自行车、骑摩托车的时光。我失去了太多。”她的儿子小斯科特刚读完七年级，他说：“我总是会想，如果爸爸还在，那会是什么样子。”
Megan Cox's mother Mary cried as she spoke of how her seven-year-old grandson had looked for his mother everywhere after she disappeared Then the day came when we found out where his mom was It was one of the worst days of our lives to tell him that his mom was dead Outside court, Charlie Carver's parents spoke of how they hoped to heal now that their son's killer was behind bars His mother Joanne said that for a while she couldn't think of Todd Kohlep without feeling furious But now she just considered him a sad man At Kohlep's sentencing, his lawyers had assured the court that he had no other victims, but some found this hard to believe His first serious crime had been committed when he was just 15, and his second followed only two years after his release from prison
梅根·考克的母亲玛丽在谈到她七岁的孙子在母亲失踪后到处寻找妈妈时哭了起来。“后来有一天，我们得知了他妈妈的下落。告诉他妈妈已经去世，是我们一生中最糟糕的日子之一。”庭外，查理·卡弗的父母谈到，既然儿子的杀手已身陷囹圄，他们希望能够开始疗伤。他的母亲乔安妮说，有一段时间她一想到托德·科尔普就感到愤怒。但现在她只觉得他是个可怜人。在科尔普的量刑听证会上，他的律师向法庭保证他没有其他受害者，但有些人对此表示怀疑。他第一次严重犯罪是在15岁时，而第二次犯罪发生在他出狱后仅两年。
It seemed unlikely that a repeat offender with a violent streak and an easily triggered inferiority complex had been a law-abiding citizen between late 2003 when he committed the Superbike Massacre and 2015 when he murdered Johnny and Megan Coxy When he provided a detailed confession to investigators, he claimed that he'd also shot and killed a boy in Tempe, Arizona when he was 14 as part of a gang initiation Kohlep said he couldn't recall any names Investigators in Arizona looked into this claim, but weren't able to verify it They also looked into other unsolved homicides and missing persons cases between 1983 to 1986, the years Kohlep was living in the area Nothing else appears to have been linked to him But there may have been another unsolved rape in Tempe that Kohlep committed 16 days before Kohlep had ducted and raped his neighbor Katie in 1986, a college student in her early 20s was attacked in her home
一个有暴力倾向且容易产生自卑感的惯犯，在2003年底犯下超级摩托车大屠杀案到2015年谋杀约翰尼和梅根·考克西之间，似乎不太可能是一个守法公民。当他向调查人员提供详细供词时，他声称自己在14岁时曾作为帮派入会仪式的一部分，在亚利桑那州坦佩市枪杀了一名男孩。科尔普说他不记得任何名字。亚利桑那州的调查人员调查了这一说法，但无法核实。他们还调查了1983年至1986年间（科尔普居住在该地区的年份）的其他未破凶杀案和失踪人口案件。似乎没有其他案件与他有关。但在科尔普绑架并强奸邻居凯蒂之前的16天，坦佩市可能发生了另一起未破的强奸案，一名20多岁的女大学生在自己家中遭到袭击。
She lived just blocks away from Kohlep In the early hours of the morning, she awoke to a man standing over her, sticking duct tape on her mouth He bound and then raped her The woman would later say he was like an awkward fumbly teenager as though he didn't know what he was doing Katie later described him the same way After the assault, the man whispered that he would kill the woman if she told the police, then left The victim did call police, however, and they came over to take a statement and evidence She never heard from them again, and records show the evidence was destroyed two years later
她住在离科尔普仅几个街区远的地方。凌晨时分，她醒来发现一个男人站在她上方，用胶带封住她的嘴。他捆绑并强奸了她。这名女子后来形容他就像一个笨拙的青少年，好像不知道自己在做什么。凯蒂后来也这样描述他。袭击发生后，该男子低声说如果她报警就杀了她，然后离开了。然而，受害者确实报了警，警察也过来做了笔录并收集了证据。她再也没有收到他们的消息，记录显示这些证据在两年后被销毁了。
Decades later, the story of Todd Kohlep's serial killings and previous rape conviction made national news, and the victim wondered if he was responsible for the crime against her as well Alana Jones said Kohlep had bragged that his victims numbered in the high double digits, though it wasn't clear if this was just him boasting Following his sentencing in 2017, he told authorities in South Carolina that he'd actually killed two more people He'd buried them near Interstate 26 in Spartanburg County and agreed to take investigators to the spot As of late 2022, this claim has not been confirmed There have been no updates as to whether any remains were found In 2018, a South Carolina man named Dustin Lawson pleaded guilty to 36 federal firearms charges after admitting he'd illegally sold guns and silences to Todd Kohlep Lawson had been aware that Kohlep had a previous felony conviction and wasn't permitted to own firearms
几十年后，托德·科尔普的连环杀人案和之前的强奸定罪成为了全国新闻，受害者怀疑他是否也应对针对她的罪行负责。阿兰娜·琼斯说，科尔普曾吹嘘他的受害者人数高达两位数，尽管不清楚这是否只是他的吹嘘。2017年判刑后，他告诉南卡罗来纳州的当局，他实际上还杀了另外两个人。他把他们埋在斯帕坦堡县的26号州际公路附近，并同意带调查人员去那个地点。截至2022年底，这一说法尚未得到证实。目前没有关于是否发现任何遗骸的最新消息。2018年，一名叫达斯汀·劳森的南卡罗来纳州男子承认非法向托德·科尔普出售枪支和消音器，被判犯有36项联邦枪支罪。劳森知道科尔普有重罪前科，不允许拥有枪支。
He was sentenced to seven years and four months in prison Alana Jones and a number of victims' family members filed civil suits against Todd Kohlep seeking damages A judge ordered that Kohlep pay Alana $6.3 million Other victims were also awarded significant amounts Kohlep's various assets were auctioned off and the money distributed amongst the victims, but his assets weren't enough to cover the amount he'd been ordered to pay To this day, the families of Kohlep's victims communicate in a group chat together Those who lost loved ones in the Superbike Motorsports murders have offered support to the families of Kohlep's later victims Terry Guy, who lost both his wife and stepson in the Superbike murders, formed a strong bond with the sister of victim Brian Lucas
他被判处七年零四个月监禁。阿兰娜·琼斯和多名受害者家属对托德·科尔普提起了民事诉讼，要求赔偿。法官判令科尔普赔偿阿兰娜630万美元。其他受害者也获得了巨额赔偿。科尔普的各种资产被拍卖，所得款项分配给了受害者，但他的资产不足以支付判决金额。时至今日，科尔普受害者的家属仍在群聊中保持联系。那些在超级摩托车赛车谋杀案中失去亲人的人，为科尔普后期受害者的家属提供了支持。在超级摩托车谋杀案中同时失去妻子和继子的特里·盖伊，与受害者布莱恩·卢卡斯的妹妹建立了深厚的联系。
The two grieved together and found comfort in each other Eventually, they fell in love and married For Melissa Brackman, there was a lot of sorrow in the fact that her husband never got to meet his son, Scotty But Scotty was also away for Scott to live on, as Melissa told a journalist from the CBS program 48 Hours I got to hold a piece of him again. I had his flesh and blood with me There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
两人共同分担悲伤，并从彼此身上找到了慰藉。最终，他们坠入爱河并结婚了。对于梅丽莎·布拉克曼来说，丈夫从未见过他的儿子斯科蒂是一件非常令人悲伤的事。但斯科蒂也是斯科特生命的延续，正如梅丽莎在哥伦比亚广播公司《48小时》节目中告诉记者的那样：“我又一次抱住了他的一部分。他的血肉与我同在。”目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。